I'm not interested.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes,
we're live data.
Yes.
Russell,
you going no headphones?
You're radical.
Well,
you knew that dude.
I'll take the headphones off with you.
I don't give a fuck.
Let's go.
Bring it on.
I feel better.
I feel liberated.
Not Know what the real sounded to look.
Slim and healthy.
What have you been doing?
Thank you.
I just,
I got back in the gym and I'm doing
boxing and kickboxing still and active.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
you know I'm in Oregon a lot,
so the meth is awesome up there.
They do have good speed rate for weight
control.
I would think that Oregon would be more
of like a calm down type of state as far
as drugs.
I was just there for four times.
I emailed you.
Yeah,
I love it up there man.
I would bet they're fucking the winter,
so goddamn depressing,
but I would still do it.
This winter has been just ridiculous.
It's rained for nine months straight.
There were like 500 inches in my county.
Jesus this winter,
but a beautiful green.
Oh God.
It's so lush when I just.
When you get out of the PDX airport,
it just,
you smell pine trees as soon as you walk
out of the airport.
I mean it's amazing and after being an
la,
which is just basically like this giant
desiccated Turd.
I mean it's like,
it's,
it's so nice.
Yeah.
That would be like the best place to
live.
Like if you had a place there and a
place here you go back and forth,
you deal with total dry and total when
I'm doing it kind of balance itself.
Nailed it.
Mr Russell.
Thank you.
You nailed it.
I'm commuting every week and people say,
yeah,
don't you get sick of this?
I actually love it so far,
so far.
Yeah.
So my son here,
my son is here,
he goes to school here.
In fact he goes to school right near
where we're sitting and uh,
so I have an apartment here and then a
house in Salem,
Oregon and I love it.
Going back and forth.
I'm not,
I'm kind of like a shark.
I can't,
I need to keep moving.
I don't like I get,
I feel claustrophobic and like the world
is passing me by if I'm sitting in one
place too long.
Have you always been like that?
I'm digging it.
Yeah.
Always.
I always need to be doing something and
moving.
I get I am literally claustrophobic.
Yeah.
And have you ever done an isolation
tank?
Oh my God.
Yeah,
I know when you talk about that I'm
freaked out.
That's my worst nightmare.
Whoa.
Like,
and I'm also a little bit afraid of the
dark.
I knew you were going to laugh at that.
You're gonna.
Call me a girl again.
No.
Wrong with being a girl by the way.
How dare you?
Oh yeah.
Well we'll get into that.
We'll get into that.
No,
uh,
I mean like pitch black that,
that freaks me out.
I really can't see anything.
I can't stand that.
I don't mind a very dark room if you
can.
As long as I can see something.
But if it's pitch black,
I freak the fuck out.
You know what freaks me out?
Vision Goggles.
Well,
that's what I want right then.
I'm cool if I hadn't seem so weird.
They put them on.
You feel like you're in a horror movie
or you're in one of those scenes and
most stupid ghostbuster shows where
they're down in the basement.
They always have night vision on.
Yeah.
Have you tried them on?
Yes.
Oh yeah.
I have some.
Of course you do.
For like nighttime boar hunting over
there,
whatever it is.
That is one of the reasons why they use
them
for.
Then it's scopes.
They have night vision scopes or where
you see the infrared version of the pigs
moving around.
It's very weird to look through them,
but people often mistake other things
for pigs like deer and not like that
idea.
I haven't tried them on,
but I liked that idea,
but you know like spelunking is
definitely out for me.
You know,
claustrophobic and afraid of the dark
spelunking caving.
Oh yeah.
It's like the idea of being like in a
tight one of those tight little caves
you have to like squeeze your body
through in the pitch dark and your
headlamp goes out.
I was just listening to,
it was my worst night,
asked about this family that owns a
ranch in Texas and they had these small
caves and these kids would explore and,
and then um,
they allowed some cavers,
some local,
you know,
cave explorers to go and check it out
and they crawl through this really
small,
like three foot diameter hole,
like literally crawled through it and
found two football field size caves
inside and then found out that there's
literally miles of cave systems in
there.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's incredible.
I wish I weren't terrified of it because
I love all the other stuff in the
outdoors and backpacking and camping and
hiking.
I do all that.
I love it.
But going underground is the worst
thing.
You only backpack and camp when it's a
full moon.
A No,
I'm cool with the stars.
That's good enough.
Good enough.
Headlamps,
like I said,
it was pitch black when you can't see
your hand in front of your face.
That freaks me out and I don't
understand why people,
other people don't freak out about that.
Like I'll wake up in a hotel room and I
forgot to,
or there's no light at all on for
whatever reason,
I'll freak out because I don't know
where I am.
See,
look,
look what I'm already admitting to
millions of people.
I just got here,
man.
I'm already like,
I'm already like a girl and putting up
your opening.
You keep saying girls,
if it's like a week thing that sparked
me the first time I was here,
he called me a girl.
It's stuck with me.
I'm sorry,
I don't even remember it now.
You just said you sounded like a girl
just then.
Really,
what did I say about.
I can remember what it was about.
I can't remember something.
Something really critically.
Pretty girlish pretty.
So it's been um,
portland,
the Portland area.
What are you doing up there?
So my girlfriend,
who I live with as a vice president at
willamette university and I teach part
time just for the hell of it at
Willamette.
But mostly I'm developing all these
other things.
And,
and mostly just enjoying Oregon.
So because man you can,
you can afford a hell of a house in
Salem,
Oregon for what you were paying in La.
Let me tell you.
So we're just living a lot better.
First Time in my life I've been in a
house that I enjoyed being in and that's
nice.
Yeah.
And so it's great and it's given me a
base to do these projects,
my new podcast and renegade university
and write my book.
It's great.
I have my own studio in the house and I
have my own office in the house.
So it's like kind of the command center
up there.
That's nice.
Yeah.
So it's been,
it's been pretty awesome lately.
I think it's fascinating how some places
like some cities have like a mindset.
There's a field that you get from the
city and liked the field that you get
from Portland.
Yeah,
I mean it's like it's a aware city,
you know,
and it's not a dumb city because they're
aware they're woke woke as fuck.
Yeah.
But it's like a white,
like a white bloke,
white work,
whatever.
It might logos a little pretentious.
I think somewhere along the line
Portland became like a place that
pretentious people gravitated to because
they wanted to identify like,
I'm white and I have dreadlocks.
Here I am.
You know what I mean?
Like they make really good food.
Those pretentious people,
their food carts or coffee.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They make great food and those food
trucks are out of this world.
Totally.
Yeah.
Portland is a great city,
except have you noticed the hid all the
black people this four or five of them?
I've seen,
I've only seen mountain lions.
I keep waiting to like come across the
cage where they keep them in the one
corner of the city because then it's
amazing.
Especially in like the core of Portland,
Maine part.
All you do not see any black people.
You don't see the Mexicans,
you don't see Japanese people.
It is just white people.
Dude with beards.
That's like a Pacific northwest selling
coffee.
You see more of it in.
You definitely see more black people in,
in Seattle.
So it's definitely pretty diverse.
Not fully,
but a lot of Asian folks for sure.
But uh,
yeah,
Portland,
I mean,
not even,
not even Latinos and Asians,
like how do you do that on the west
coast?
Where do you put all those people?
If you're on the west side,
pass by there,
just go with it.
Let's keep going.
Vancouver's right up the street.
Hey you,
you took a wrong turn.
Keep going.
Just keep walking.
Let's just keep going north.
Yeah.
It's like it's,
it's a small city.
I mean I don't think Portland has more
than a million people.
Right.
Does it now?
I think it's like,
it's like half a million.
Is it really?
I think something like that.
Yeah,
it's small.
I know it.
The lack of diversity actually is the
only problem I have with it and it's a
fairly big problem,
but that's an issue.
But otherwise it's the best city in
America I think.
Really.
It's my favorite city in America.
Yeah,
I should say.
It was pretty.
God damn good.
Lawrence Krauss lives there I am.
So there you go.
Yeah,
there's two of us to complete to.
Cool people are smart people.
I don't live in Portland,
right?
I live in Salem,
which is an hour south,
but we're still important that a lot,
so it's kind of is that because of the
university will and because it's way
cheaper to live there and it's also
really beautifully centrally located.
So we've got.
We're an hour and 10 minutes from the
coast,
which is gorgeous.
Have you been to the Oregon coast?
Yes.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And then we're an hour and a quarter
from the cascade mountains on the other
side.
And then all around Salem is the
Willamette valley,
which is like Napa Valley and Sonoma
county meet Vermont.
It is so beautiful.
Just readily beautiful farmland all
around there to make a lot of wine up
there.
Two incredible wine.
The pinot noir is the best in the world.
Yeah,
but it's really pretty.
Just driving through there,
so.
Whew man.
That's.
Yeah,
I'm telling you,
we have.
Salem has Mexican,
so we do have a little diversity because
all the farm workers,
there's a substantial population of
Latinos.
You have legit Mexican instead.
We got in St Louis,
uh,
not like working on it.
We're working on it.
I mean,
Salem has been like a dumpy town for a
long,
long time
until just recently.
Um,
and now it's starting to pick up.
We got some stuff going on and we've
been.
Now we've got a good mma gym there.
And a boxing gym just just opened.
Legitimate.
Yeah,
like team quest people,
former team quest people.
What was the trainers?
Nick Gilardi who's a,
he actually came up with chill and randy
couture,
he was,
he was trained as a wrestler by them
when they were doing wrestling only when
he was a kid and then he became a
champion wrestler and then they went
into fighting and he was like,
okay,
I'll do that with you.
And he's a major sort of northwest mma
fighter and now he's like,
coach of the year in the northwest.
Oh Great.
He's my coach.
We have a little image.
It's really good mma gym in,
uh,
in Salem called impact.
That's awesome.
Impact Jujitsu.
So your knee is.
We're talking about this before the
podcast you need,
feels like it's good enough.
And I really would love to start
grappling.
I never have.
And I'm scared of it because of all the
takes,
especially the take downs and you know,
and the leg locks and all that.
So I don't know,
but I'm doing it.
I'm still doing just standup boxing and,
and um,
and Moitai kick boxing.
Have you ever done any yoga?
Yes.
It's great for me.
Uh,
I can help my knee.
It will definitely help your name.
I guess so.
I mean stretching it,
help.
Just strengthening and strengthening.
I mean just holding static positions
like static yoga positions for your back
and for your knees and your feet until
this does.
I'm a broken record with this shit.
So I'll stop right now.
Lost people.
People listening to this podcast like
Jesus is gonna fucking talk about yoga
again.
I love it.
Yeah.
So we don't,
we don't have to talk.
No,
no,
that's,
I'm all about that drink gatorade man.
Cause I'm,
I'm.
This is not good for you.
That's triggering.
This is terrible for you that you might
as well be drink because I get dry mouth
around it.
You scare me.
I'm sorry.
I'm just kidding.
He's scared of the dark.
Scared of scary looking at you,
Mr. Muscles.
Listen,
now that you're all leaned out,
you're scared of muscle people.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
um,
it's interesting place.
It's a,
it's a truly sort of like it's trump
country,
trump country.
It's like,
it's,
it's dudes with beards who are not
hipsters who drive pickup drugs real and
have a lot of guns and um,
they don't give a fuck basically.
And it's sort of,
um,
it's not really a conservative socially
conservative place is more of a kind of
libertarian thing and basically this is
my land,
don't mess with me.
So it very much was the libertarian
option kind of kind of,
kind of.
Most Libertarians hated him,
so they would be better off with someone
who's an actual libertarian like Ron
Paul.
He's type character.
He's the only reason libertarians were
attracted.
Well,
there's two reasons,
but the main one was that they were
attracted to him because during the
campaign at least he was saying things
that sounded like he was a non
interventionist in foreign policy.
Right.
And that's why I was at least interested
in him.
I thought there was a possibility there.
Of course he would like,
you know,
for 30 minutes he would talk like Ron
Paul about foreign policy and then the
last 30 minutes of his speech he would
sound like an old republican about how
you wanted to bomb the shit out of
people.
So who knows.
But now of course,
I think what's happened is that the
generals have taken over.
I think establishment has just taken
over.
Well,
it seems like there's,
there's no way one person can run every
single facet of being the president,
especially not him.
Yeah.
And he's got 100 different businesses
worldwide that are constantly ongoing
right now.
Anything about the world.
So of course he's going to rely on
experts and he also,
we all knew this all along.
He loves generals.
He loves that thing.
And I,
I,
it's pretty clear that madness came in
there and just took over his mind.
And um,
he said,
okay,
yeah,
I guess you,
I was right about all that shit.
Let's go.
Essentially said I'm going to get out of
their way and let the military do their
job.
Exactly.
And like I know guys that are like
re-enlisting because they're pumped.
They think that the military,
like Tim Kennedy a UFC fighter,
he reenlisted enlisted because he
believes that the UFC forever,
the UFC,
he believes that the military now has
the backing and the support from the
president and that this is going to be
great and they can do their job.
Now.
Kennedy,
one to,
uh,
serve in combat because he really was.
He really wants to go to oil and
possibly die.
Oh yeah.
He's doing that right now because he
believes in the car.
Does he belong to percent?
Yeah.
Where?
Which part?
I talked to him about it.
Isis.
What does he want?
He wants to kill his.
He's about Isis.
Oh Dude.
It gives his address out to isis.
Puts his address on the Internet.
Says fine.
Come get me.
I'd love to talk to Tim Kennedy.
Yeah.
It's a long conversation though.
I bet you would want six hours.
That's fine.
You would want to take pee breaks and
drink water.
And this.
Let's get into this from top to bottom.
I would love to want this smoothed out.
CNN.
Seven minute presentation in between two
talking heads on either side.
You don't want that.
You want the long form.
Who is Tim Kennedy had?
Why?
Why does Tim Kennedy feel this way?
And that's what I will do.
An experience that's my podcast,
unregistered podcast.
That's what we do.
And it's,
it's kind of a,
yeah,
that's precisely what we're doing.
I'm interested in people's personal
histories and how it's connected to
their current ideas,
right?
The roots of their political ideas,
where do they come from?
So it requires people who are self aware
about themselves and a lot of,
a lot of people aren't,
but so far my guests are people who
really have a sense of the connections
between what happened in their childhood
and the early development and,
and what they're thinking now.
It's a really interesting thing if you
can get people to do that,
to connect those things,
to weave them together.
So if Tim Kaine,
I mean Tim Kennedy might know,
uh,
where his ideas about serving in the
military come from other than,
you know,
my dad did it or,
or whatever it was.
But that's what I'm interested in doing.
So and this form like what you're doing
here,
the long form.
I love it.
It's so much better.
I think this is why I've know a lot of
people didn't know me.
I take most of the people who know me
know me from my podcast appearances here
and elsewhere have been on a lot of
podcasts and I just,
I,
I'm just more comfortable with it.
I just think it's the best way to go.
I hate being on cable news where it's
like,
you know,
two minutes or 30 seconds and get this
complicated idea out right then and
that's it.
And even radio have done a lot of radio
which just sucks,
you know,
it's the same thing.
Twenty second sound bytes,
even 20 minute interviews.
I always find frustrating either as an
interviewer or as a guest,
even our long interviews.
Oh totally.
I did an interview with Ron miscavige is
the father of data and we only did an
hour and a half and I was like,
if we did like three or four hours,
I probably get deeper and deeper into
the student and find out,
well,
yeah,
that's it.
That's what you do.
So you go kind of,
you're always going in and out of
people's personal histories and their
psychology and then into their ideas and
into big abstract stuff.
And then history and philosophy and
science,
right?
You're going in and always back and
forth and ended up connecting those
things,
weaving together.
That's.
I love that.
I think it's the only way to go.
You get the deepest understanding of
people and it's,
it sort of makes it impossible to do
what most people do is,
which has just put people in a little
box and throw them away.
Right.
Dismissed,
you know,
oh,
he's a libertarian,
he's a socialist or whatever,
dawn.
Right.
Um,
so you know,
he's Joe Rogan.
Oh,
he's the UFC guy.
Gone,
right?
And I'm sure people do that to you all
the shore,
or he's Joe Rogan,
the masculine macho dude not interested
by,
right.
Everyone is so complex.
Um,
most people are and most people are not
the same person who they were.
If you're pulling a quote from them from
two years ago or five years ago or
whatever,
I'm just not that person anymore.
Everybody evolves.
Exactly.
And you can box someone into some sort
of a corner by like,
not to defend them,
but the,
grab them by the Pussy speech from 2005
for example.
It's your boxing,
a guy in the corner who's trying to make
another guy laugh on a bus and he's just
being gross.
Greg's.
And then you take that and go,
is this the guy who won for president?
Right.
Yeah.
We can talk about that a lot.
I mean,
I'm with you on that when I heard you
talking about that the other day.
But yeah,
it's the trump.
I have a lot to say about that.
But um,
it's,
um,
so anyway,
I think the podcasting thing,
it's changing the game and it's,
it's so great.
It gives people something to do while
they're doing other stuff.
Totally.
I think we're like 90 percent audio,
only downloads versus youtube,
somewhere,
somewhere in route.
So most people are either listening
during the commute or while they're at
the gym or a lot of people even at work,
they'll put on headphones while they're
doing mindless bullshit,
but I think what it does is it humanizes
people,
right?
You get,
you get not the full humanity of a
person of course,
but you get much more of who they are
really and the complexities of them and
so people talk about how we are all
being siloed now because of the
Internet.
Right?
That we just go to the websites we do
that agree with us and there's a lot of
that for sure.
Certainly,
but I think there's.
I actually think the overall effect is
just the opposite.
I actually think that we have much
deeper understandings of people who are
not like us because of things like this.
Right?
I mean,
because of the podcasts and because
there's just much more exposure to
people's ideas and personalities and
there's.
There's more people talking in public,
by the way,
I mean,
just imagine that,
right?
Like in the 19 seventies and eighties
when you and I were growing up,
there were three broadcast that all
said the same thing on the new shows.
There were three also said the same
thing because the FCC wouldn't allow any
competitors to come into the market.
I mean they just wouldn't allow it.
And then Rupert Murdoch broke that open.
Right?
And then since then it's just been
flooded.
So now we have how many channels,
how many networks?
I'm going to end up podcasts and so when
I was coming up as an academic in the
nineties,
if you didn't,
if your book didn't get reviewed in the
New York Times or if you're an author of
any kind and your book didn't get
reviewed in the New York Times,
you were not going to make a living as a
writer.
That was it.
You had to get reviewed in the New York
Times and it had to be a positive
review.
That was the only gatekeeper to success
as an author.
Now the New York Times is one of,
you know,
a hundred different places are a
thousand different places that matter
when you're writing books.
My book renegade history,
the United States was ignored entirely
by the New York Times and I know why,
but it didn't really matter.
People fly.
Oh,
because it says all the things you're
not supposed to say if you're a good
liberal left liberal by coastal elite
person from university.
Like,
like,
um,
Martin Luther King was a conservative
and hated black culture,
you know,
like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was a very conservative person
culturally,
and he was basically an opponent of
black culture.
He,
he didn't,
he was opposed to rock and roll.
He didn't,
he didn't even mention jazz until the
19,
late,
late into his career.
And only once he thought black people
should sing classical music,
European classical music or,
or Gospel,
you know,
very respectable,
very Christian,
very good citizen kind of stuff.
And he hated the flamboyant black
preachers who were hooping and hollering
in the,
in their churches and speak in black
dialect.
He wanted every,
all black people to speak,
correct American English.
Um,
he was opposed to a lot of dancing that
was going on.
He just,
all this stuff that we love in black
culture,
Martin Luther King was opposed to,
it wasn't because he was just an
uptight,
puritanical prick.
It was because of his strategy and his
objective,
which was to seek full citizenship.
Right.
And he understood right?
In a way it wasn't his fault entirely.
You have to prove yourself always in
this country historically that you are
just like white people to get all the
good stuff to get the vote to get equal
protection under the law.
So that's what his mission was.
Assimilation,
assimilation has always been the ticket
to full citizenship man.
It's just,
it sucks that that's even a thought that
the only way to achieve quote unquote
full citizenship is to ignore all the
things that make black culture special.
Like comedy,
like Jazz,
like rap,
like just,
just slang,
just all the cool shit that black people
have figured out.
Like the things to say that white people
have ruined.
Like bro,
bro used to be like a cool thing.
Oh yeah,
black people say to each other and now
it's like an insult for a like a frat
dummies a bro.
Now we'll just think about like,
thinking about America now,
if black people had never been here,
what would it be like?
Which I'm not sure I'd want to live
here.
We wouldn't even have blues.
So like what kind of musical we have.
Blues is the roots of all pop music,
but all music comes out of blues.
Everything that's pop music that's not
European.
Classical music has comes from black
people.
Original roots basically.
Of course whites were involved in it,
you know,
of course all that music but,
but all that stuff,
the roots of it are in this lives.
It will even European rock,
like led Zeppelin will.
They borrowed it.
Those guys asked the Beatles.
They talked about this stuff.
The stones,
you talked about it all the time.
They like a,
you know,
we're not,
we are not the rolling stones without
muddy waters.
Of course.
Les said it to all of that sort of
stemmed from.
It's fascinating when you really think
about.
So that's the whole history of.
That's African American history actually
is a ordinary black people who aren't
interested in being just like white
people and doing their thing,
you know,
since slavery,
I'm just doing their thing and being
called niggers by whites and also,
and this is what people don't know,
civil rights leaders since slavery,
like black political leaders who wanted
citizenship,
attacking them for their culture just as
harshly as the Ku Klux Klan did.
And I'm not exaggerating if you look at
what Frederick Douglas said about slave
culture,
if you look at what Web Dubois sometimes
said about slave culture and black
culture than Martin Luther King,
a Philip Randolph,
Jesse Jackson,
Al Sharpton,
all the way through,
they are saying the harshest nastiest
things about black working class,
popular culture you could imagine.
But again,
it was for this reason,
they wanted to convince whites that we
are just like them.
So they'll let us in the.
Let us sit at the table of America.
They'll give us the vote.
We can then become president.
And so guess what happened?
They finally,
a guy came along who was black looking,
but who,
who lived in this perfect nuclear
Christian family wife,
two kids didn't drink,
didn't do drugs,
he smoked,
but he stopped smoking pretty quickly.
Right?
Very dignified,
spoke perfect English.
Right?
And guess what happened?
He became our first black president.
So Obama is absolutely the apotheosis is
a good academic word.
He's the pinnacle.
He's the,
he's the full achievement of that long
attempt by civil rights leaders,
black political leaders to assimilate
blacks and they won in that way.
They got a president.
But what else did they win?
Right?
And doing that.
Not much.
I mean race relations.
Now,
are they better now?
Not really.
Do Black people still say stuff in their
hip hop songs that is not respectable
even more than ever.
Um,
and white people or black people are
thinking when they're doing their hip
hop songs,
they're not thinking that they're
representing.
All black people are thinking they're
representing their vision right there,
representing what they see on the
street,
what they see in their neighborhood.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's always going to be the case,
right?
The people.
This is the thing,
you know,
I mean people who actually are from
those neighborhoods,
you know,
where there really aren't any white
people,
you know,
if they're from the projects are,
they're from,
you know,
these poor black neighborhoods that are
famous,
right?
I mean by and large,
and we know this from what they say in
their art,
you know,
don't give a shit about what white
people think about them,
right?
They're not interested in citizenship.
They're not interested in being good
Americans.
They're doing their thing,
as you just said.
I mean,
they're interested in represent seems to
me they're interested in representing
their aspirations and their interested
in having a good time,
which sounds trivial to a lot of people,
but it's actually revolutionary,
right?
If you just,
if you're interested only in having a
good time and pleasure and succeeding
and achieving things for yourself,
that's actually not American because
you're not interested in America.
You're interested,
interested in yourself.
So that's a person who's very unlikely
to volunteer like Tim Kennedy to go
serve in the military.
Right?
It's very unlikely that that person will
become a cop.
It's unlikely that that person will obey
the laws,
will obey the,
the,
the actual laws and then the cultural
laws.
They're not going to be good Americans.
They're out for themselves and I think
that's actually always historically for
more than 200 years provided this
alternative for white people.
We've always looked at that like with
this sort of Split Lens,
like part of it says,
Goddamn,
look at those.
Look at those primitive black people.
They do.
They're doing the bad stuff.
We were not like them.
We're better than that and always
simultaneously,
most or many white people have looked at
and said,
hm,
that looks.
That looks more fun than what we're
doing.
Maybe we'll do that for a while.
Certainly young white,
suburban kids that grow up in these
safe,
sheltered environment,
it's always adopt that sort of a radical
bad ass black rapper,
sort of listening to their music,
wearing their pants low,
like sag and doing all that stuff.
Coopting various aspects of black
culture that seemed to be dangerous.
You know who you just described who?
My son.
Oh No,
no.
Don't say,
oh no,
it's good as you sagging.
I'm saying I'm pro wigger,
son sags.
They don't sag anymore.
This is the new thing is these ripped
jeans.
That's hip hop style chips.
Genes behind the top,
kind of like fitted.
They don't sag,
but they're like just shredded almost
like an eighties look.
And I said,
I said to my son,
I said,
you know,
back in the eighties,
like we laughed at those genes but for a
totally different reason and now that's
the coolest thing that black people
were.
Oh,
so he's doing all that.
He's.
He is fully immersed.
He is.
He studies rap lyrics.
He knows all that stuff.
How old is he?
He's making beats.
He's 15.
Yeah.
So
it kind of martial arts,
queer kind of see why train?
I'm saying no,
he refused.
Really?
I tried to get them in there a couple
times.
Good for discipline that Joe Schilling
and I think that scared scared of me
when I met Joe.
Scary Dude was my first gym.
I walked in the first day and I had
never done anything like that and I walk
in and there was job and I was like,
okay,
if people like that are going to be
doing this,
I'm not.
I'm not having any part of this name is
just terrifying,
but when you get to know him,
he's a teddy bear.
He's awesome and big old sweet.
Awesome.
Great coach.
Great Guy.
Yeah.
I love.
Just think for a young boy,
like it's a great way to sort your head
out.
I think life is so I.
If I didn't find martial arts when I was
that age,
who the fuck knows what started when I
was.
I was just thinking about this.
I started when I was 41.
Wow.
Yeah.
I took my suffering is doxing lesson
when I was 41.
Wow.
How's Your Double Jab?
Church street really took off the job.
Oh yeah.
Hell yeah.
If you started at 41.
Yeah.
Got some speed to it.
I got a good job.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Interesting.
Told this tall guy.
I got some holes in my game.
Think about Klitschko a Joshua.
This weekend's during fight pouring.
Those guys are boring.
Joshua's got nice job,
was not boring.
He's.
He's got great power.
Is Techniques okay?
He's not great.
I think Klitschkos got a nice jacket,
put people to sleep.
So this is why the heavyweight division,
no one cares about it,
right?
People to sleep the other way by being
boring and being not silly,
but Joshua puts people to sleep.
Josh,
he knocks people out,
which is fun to watch and I'm into that,
but it's not.
I like,
I just love technique.
Like I'm a student,
so like Loma Chenko Guy.
So thank you for bringing La Loma.
Thank you for bringing him up.
We got to talk about this.
Forget my career podcast.
History.
Fuck all this shit.
Who Don't know.
Go on right now.
And Google Vasiliy Loma Chenko.
He might be the best boxer that's ever
lived.
He might be.
So I was worried about that.
We were going to fight about this,
but I think we're on the same page here.
So he's on such another level.
So I footwork and movement.
I just can't come up with a comparable.
I mean there's been some amazing boxers
way back to sugar ray Robinson and
Willie pap and all those guys paved the
way,
but I feel like everything evolves,
right?
Every combat sport,
even art and music evolves to the
current state it's at now,
which you get the best of the best right
now and you go,
wow.
They've learned from Ali and Sugar Ray
Leonard and Roy Jones and Bernard
Hopkins and Loma Chenko is in my eyes,
is the best way he moves is insane.
Yeah,
and he's super aggressive.
He's not like floyd mayweather who is
arguably the best ever,
you know,
multiple time world champion in multiple
divisions.
Forty nine in.
Oh,
only been like hit solid maybe seven,
eight times his whole salary once when
he got a little rock by Shane once and
then my donna cracked him once,
but that's like over the course of this
spectacular career,
but much more defensive oriented,
brilliantly defensive,
very economical with this approach,
but brutal hands hurts them,
hurts his hand,
breaks his hands a lot.
Not a lot of power.
Loma Chenko is on you like glue stands
right in front of you and you can't hit
him.
And he's going left and he's going right
and he's in and he's out and you don't
know where the fuck he is and he's
lightening you up.
So what does this.
Here's why Wassily Lemme check goes.
Now the number one pound for pound
fighter in boxing.
What's that in Forbes?
Damn,
for.
Technically he can't be because his
record,
he doesn't.
He hasn't really been tested.
He goes,
no,
I'm,
I'm with you completely.
I'm just saying technically he doesn't
have enough fights.
I don't give a fuck to be number one.
I know he's the best.
So let me just say so here's my history.
Let me try again so I can figure.
It was like four or five years ago I
thought Gary Russell Jr was the greatest
thing since sliced bread and I still
think he's just phenomenal.
Incredibly fast.
The fastest hands since Roy Jones easily
and maybe even faster,
just technically just perfect.
I thought he was unbeatable.
I thought he was the next thing and he's
still great.
Great.
Great fighter.
I love him.
He fought Lemme check on.
I was like,
who's this Russian dude?
I don't even know.
He's your cranium.
Never heard of him.
And he took.
He took russell apart.
Yeah.
Here's a highlight reel.
Look it.
He stands right in front of people.
Man.
He just has such brilliant movement,
man.
I mean,
he's like the perfect example of like
the new wave like this state right
there.
What do you want this side to movement?
Yeah,
he does this.
He does this.
It's a hop.
Actually.
He hops inside and he'll throw a body
shot off of it when it gets inside on
you,
but he's basically standing at your
side.
Boom.
Like right there.
I did it again.
It's not like a brutal puncher.
He'll step in or hop in and you know,
the funny thing is,
so I've been hopping around Jim's
lately,
boxing gyms.
He's,
he did it like three times in a row and
here's how.
Here's how I know.
Here's always there.
Here's why I think that he is the next
Ali,
which is that just in the last year,
every boxing gym up,
gone to.
People have taught Loma Chanko moves
like as a standard part of classes.
Interesting.
Right?
Meaning that he's changing the game.
It's Kinda what you were saying.
Well,
you know Mike Tyson did a lot of that
too,
by the way.
People can to this lunch is hard as Mike
Tyson.
You can actually do some of this stuff.
Of course.
He's a phenomenal athlete.
Loma Chanko is,
and not everyone can do this,
but there are some things here that you
can do that had never been done before.
Like in particular,
that little hop step.
It's actually,
I had a coach call it the,
I think it was called the Loma Chieko
jump or something,
but you can do that.
You can.
You can just step in like that really
quickly,
but people for some reason just never
did it.
Well,
Tyson did do it.
Tyson learned it from customer.
No,
custom motto was teaching this way back
in the fifties,
but his,
his style was Mike Tyson style was so
much different because he was throwing
howitzers at you.
It's Loma Chanko is not knocking anybody
out with one punch.
No,
no.
He's hitting you with multiple barrage
of punches,
but the thing about they dropped him
with a liver shot,
but the thing about like what Loma
Chanko is doing with this steady barrage
is very similar to what I've always said
about Jujitsu.
Like if you want to really learn Jujitsu
Jujitsu from a small man because small
men can't use strength and weight and
all the physical advantages they have to
use perfect technique.
So if you deal with guys like Eddie
Bravo or Heuler gracie or a Barrett
Yoshida,
like the really little guys are the guys
who have this stellar techniques because
they don't have the physical strength
with Loma Chanko,
you've seen the same thing.
He's not a one punch guy.
He doesn't have like some Tommy hearns
Nacada ability or Mike Tyson type power,
so he's forced to have this brilliant
movement and footwork which is complete
next level.
The footwork I think is the best of all
time and now he's literally embracing
the whole idea of him being in the
Matrix.
Has Matrix shorts on now.
See,
I like the matrix comparison.
I think of him as the nightcrawler.
Like,
you know,
he's just teleporting around you.
He's just,
he just shows up suddenly right next to
him.
Right.
He disappears and shows up right next to
you in a different location there that,
that little movement and the
anticipation of the counter and already
been to three steps ahead of you.
That last fight against Sosa.
Yeah,
I saw that.
That was even better.
Even he improved.
He was even better.
I was like,
this is getting crazy.
Like it's so amazing.
Everyone should watch him.
He's,
he's on another level man on a complete
nother level.
So yeah,
for this,
a guy like him and kickboxing who?
Giorgio Petrosyan,
Georgia patrols and he's my best for
sure.
Yeah.
This is some next level shit too.
Definitely.
Yeah,
I think so.
He did lose one fight by knockout a
couple of years ago,
but yeah.
Badly by Daniel Lee logos and rusty and
rusty,
that's what it was.
Yeah.
Well risk is a brutal knockout punch or
knocked out a van.
Rhys Millen to same year I think.
Well,
it's one of those things where a guy
like any university has so much power.
If he catches a human being on the chin,
not perfect technique,
but men,
but nasty,
nasty power.
Yeah.
I wanted to talk about Jermaine to
randomly.
Oh yeah.
Talking about her.
I mean,
because,
uh,
it's funny that we're talking about
fighting.
I'm so happy I want to do well.
This podcast really,
you know,
I don't know.
It's not real format to it.
We've all noticed joe millions of us and
notice what is great about it.
Uh,
it wasn't going to say no.
I mean,
I,
um,
it's funny.
I think the first time I was on here a
couple of years ago,
I said at the end that I wanted to be a
surfer.
Deep Down,
you know,
like I love what I do and being a
historian,
all this stuff.
But deep down I wanted to be a surfer.
Now I don't want to be a surfer.
I want to be a boxing coach.
Really?
Yeah.
I really do.
A lot of people that are intellectuals,
a lot of people that live on almost like
a sedentary lifestyle because you're
constantly in front of books or computer
screens.
They long for this sense of adventure,
I want to be a backpack or I want to go
to Nepal and most most academics,
and maybe this is one of the reasons I
had to leave that profession or I'm
trying to leave that profession,
is that I've always been a physical
person to.
I've always been,
you know,
just in touch with my body in various
ways.
I've always been into sports,
playing them and doing stuff.
I just,
you know,
and most academics I'd say or least a
lot of them seem
to be completely cut off from their
bodies.
They just don't care what's below the
neck.
Uh,
they don't care what they wear,
they don't care how they feel.
They certainly don't care.
They look many of them and they don't
talk about the body.
They don't talk about things like this
ever.
And in full they looked down on it.
The problem is the looking down on it.
I think that's very shortly this
conversation right now we had about
boxing.
If you just took that clip that last 10
minutes and you put that in front of and
you sent that to every historian and the
country,
I mean,
my reputation will be done.
it's already pretty much done yet.
Are you serious?
I appreciate box.
I love talking to people who aren't from
that world.
When I tell them about these things and
they're like,
oh,
of course that couldn't be.
It's not that bad.
Well,
what a silly world that is.
Then it's bad.
They would think less of me.
Well,
um,
but yeah,
no,
I want to be a boxing coach.
I'm not,
I definitely.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know if I can really make
it happen professionally,
but you know,
at least on the side,
you know,
we'd have to have a couple fights.
So anything.
That's what I'm wondering.
I don't know.
I mean,
I certainly can't coach pros,
but I mean I'm talking about people sort
of like at my levels,
people who spar maybe,
maybe some amateur fighters.
I mean,
I'm working like a little bit with a guy
in my gym who's trying to be an amateur
boxer now,
but I'm not his coach.
I'm just saying I'm sort of like trying
to see because he's brand new to this
point.
Um,
and I just love it.
I love it.
I love teaching,
I love teaching and that's the thing
about academia that have always just
loved.
And that's why I entered it because I
just felt like I was,
it was just natural for me teaching
people things.
Teaching is fun,
man.
If you're good at it,
but most people are not.
Yeah.
Right.
So when you teach Jujitsu,
right?
I mean,
what you're doing is,
and this goes for anything.
If you're teaching how to fix a bike,
right?
You take,
you're taking all these complex ideas
and this is what you're a master at a.
You take all these really complex ideas
and you package them,
you,
you break them down into little bite
sized components and then hand them over
to the person,
right?
You give them so that they can consume
it and understand it instead of just
saying,
oh,
that's the Japanese necktie.
Go ahead do it.
Right.
Which is what you'll see a lot of
teachers do.
Here's how.
Here's how you do a Japanese necktie.
Now go ahead and do it right.
You're like,
okay,
no,
the elbow goes here.
I mean a lot of Jujitsu instructors do
this too,
of course.
But like you know,
the elbow goes right here,
an inch down there and then the knees
here and then.
Right and so it's.
But it's just like what I do,
I mean,
you take these really complex abstract
concepts,
you know that and you give them back to
two people who are completely new to
them.
You have to,
you have to package it.
Not,
not dumb it down,
but distill it right?
You have to like bring the,
the essential components down and get
rid of all the extraneous stuff and then
just hand it over to them and this is a
very clear,
simple way.
And then you can give them,
give them the next part and then you
connect that and then you connect that
and next thing you know,
they have this new radical concept of
Martin Luther King or they can do a
Japanese necktie.
That's what separates someone who's a
really good teacher versus someone who
has maybe some real skill at something
but isn't good at communicating here.
Like breaking it down into a system,
like a step by step progression system.
Yeah.
My coach I was talking about in Salem,
Nick Gelardi,
I've got
to give them a shout out because he's
awesome.
He's one of the best.
What's that?
I said powerful nick.
Yeah,
he is.
He,
um,
he's one of the best coaches I've ever
seen because he,
he's really a coach's coach.
Like he really cares about coaching and
teaching.
He really cares about teaching.
And that's what he does.
I could stop.
He'll.
So he said he was at team quest guy.
He comes down.
So Robert Follis,
who is also an awesome coach who know he
was,
he started out with them and now he's a,
he's extreme coture now.
Yeah,
he's worked with a lot of like top level
guys,
but yeah,
I mean that's when the sport was being
invented by.
Sure.
Yeah,
so he was at the beginning of that as a
kid with Dan Henderson,
Matt Lindland,
you know,
randy coture,
but I think it's just that I don't think
it's about his context.
I think it's about who he is as a person
just like me.
It's like it's not.
No one trained me to be a teacher.
Like when I was in,
when I was taking,
when I entered college,
I had no idea was going to be a teacher,
but I remember sitting in his college
classes that kind of weren't very good
and I remember that I'd spent a lot of
my time thinking about how I would teach
this differently than this guy was
teaching it.
And then I realized,
oh wait,
I just,
I,
I'm actually studying the teaching more
than the subject itself,
how to communicate these ideas.
I was studying more than the subject
itself and then I just do.
It dawned on me finally.
I was like,
oh,
well that means you probably should be a
teacher.
And when I finally started doing it in
graduate school at Columbia,
I was teaching,
you know,
philosophy actually.
And yeah,
I just,
I loved it.
It was just my passion.
Do you find that?
Will is you teach things that it helps
you better understand them too because
you go over them from a real fundamental
perspective?
Precisely.
Right,
so you don't.
And that was the first thing I learned
when I started teaching was that I
thought I knew plato really well,
you know,
until I started,
until I knew that I had to teach him the
next day and I was like,
oh,
wait a minute.
I didn't quite actually get that
connection there between those two ideas
in his book,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to.
I tell my students this all the time.
I said,
you need to be as comfortable,
so comfortable with this text that you
can teach it to your roommate who's
never read it before.
That means what that means is you have
to think all the way through the ideas.
You have to go all with your mind all
the way through the ideas and then come
back through them.
Right.
It's just like it's like martial arts or
anything else,
like you have to actually do the
Japanese neck necktie all the way
through and come back all the way
through it and then you can teach it all
the way through taekwondo career I
taught.
I taught at Boston University.
I taught my own school.
I taught classes.
I taught the entire time.
It's one other way.
I made a living.
I didn't know that and it helped me
tremendously.
It helped me understand it and I didn't
realize how much it helped me until I
started doing Jujitsu and I watched
other people who started teaching
Jujitsu just jump ahead by leaps and
bounds from where they were.
A good example is my friend Brent,
he was a like a purple belt and he was
always like a certain level,
kind of a static level and then not
static,
but you know improving,
but nothing crazy.
It was like everybody else.
Right.
What?
Jujitsu is hard.
It takes a long time to get better and
you're around other people that are also
getting better,
so it's hard to look really measure,
you know,
but then he started teaching and
teaching full time and then all the
sudden I would roll with him and I'd be
in great danger and I be like,
Jesus and I had a conversation with them
once,
after a training with them,
like,
dude,
I don't know what the fuck you're doing,
but your,
your game has jumped like four or five
steps ahead.
Like I feel like I'm the same as I was
six,
seven months ago.
And he was like years ahead and he said
it was all just teaching.
And,
and I remember now that that was the
first time I really felt confident as an
intellectual,
you know,
as when you were teaching the subjects
at once I had taught them,
it was like,
oh,
now I actually feel I was always.
I mean everybody's wracked with
insecurity and especially in graduate
school about these things.
You know,
everybody feels like an imposter because
we all,
there's all,
all of us have,
you know,
500 bucks that everyone else has read
that you should have read that we
haven't read.
And I came from this little dip shit
college in Ohio and I was like a c
student in high school,
so I had an extra insecurity,
but once I started teaching it and
forcing myself to,
as you said,
like learn the thing all the way through
it and master it and then teaching it,
that's when I felt,
oh yeah,
I belong here.
I get it.
I really do have some solid
understanding of plato now and I really,
I really can do this thing.
You know,
it's interesting that you're saying that
because that's a big issue with
comedians too.
And like as they're becoming successful,
especially they feel like frauds.
Like everybody I know says that I've
said it.
Everybody I know that's sort of like
started to make it like as they're
starting to headline and go on the road
places and do television sets and things
along those lines.
Do you feel like a fraud when you're
successful?
Yes,
I feel like a fraud.
You like,
I'm,
you know,
because you'll look at yourself and then
you'll look at,
you know,
a Dave Chappelle or someone else,
Chris Rock and you're like,
well,
I'm a fucking fraud.
I'm a fraud.
I'm not that guy.
I'm not Richard,
Jenny,
I'm a fraud.
And then I'm sure it takes a long time
before you feel comfortable enough to
say,
I know what I'm doing in academia.
It's called the Charlatans Syndrome,
right?
We all feel like we're charlatan.
I think it exists in everything.
Everything difficult.
I'm not surprised and I think it's also
probably a hallmark of someone who
cares.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's what makes you better.
Yeah.
I don't think every academic has that,
but I think those who do are the ones
who were interesting and get better.
I think the worst would be the opposite.
Someone who's like super confident way
before their time.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Yeah.
They're going to suck.
There's a lot of that too though,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of weirdness in academia,
man.
No kidding.
I can't imagine the stuff that you guys
go through politically.
Oh my God,
because just you saying that you
couldn't talk about boxing because you
would be thought of as a fool.
So that's the thing.
I know you're really interested in this
and I am too and I'm the.
There are some misconceptions and that.
Well,
I shouldn't say their misconceptions.
I would say that there's a distortion of
what's going on and this is not to say
it's,
it's
actually to say that it's worse than you
think it is.
So what most people who are outside of
academia think is going on is not quite
what's going on.
We think it's something worse.
Well,
I know because I've heard her do.
You have lots and lots of other people
talk about and it's not your fault at
all because you're not there and all you
do is get the media reports about it.
So I think what most people,
I get it from Gad sad and Jordan
Peterson or professors,
they end day.
If you listen to them,
actually they will.
They themselves.
We'll talk about it a little
differently,
but people still consume it differently
because the news right is all about the
crazy thing that the 18 year old said at
Wesleyan or whatever,
or it's not the 18 year old.
It's the 45 year old sometimes the 45
year old.
Yeah.
Okay.
But here's the.
So that stuff that really sort of loony
stuff,
you know,
that you hear coming out or protest,
people saying that they are,
I'm going to die because you said a word
that happens.
It does.
That's all true.
It's all there.
I've seen it,
but I've seen it maybe at most one time
a year in the colleges where I've been.
Maybe not even less than that.
Okay.
What is.
And if it were just that,
that's not actually a big deal.
It's much worse than that.
What's what's worse is that if there is
a self censorship going on that's
universal and profound,
constant omnipresent.
Like for instance,
you know,
I never talk about my love for boxing
around academics or I'm very careful if
I do,
but it's not even that.
It's that we know that there are certain
things that can't be set on a college
campus and so we just don't say them,
therefore there's no need to police us.
There's no need to yell at us and
screaming us in protest and what's the
motivation for the for which are the
people that are holding back on thoughts
that maybe they would normally express.
Okay.
Well here's what I think it is for the
senior faculty who have tenure,
meaning lifetime appointments,
cowardice.
That's all it is.
I think they're cowards.
Yeah.
If you are an adjunct like me with no
job security or if you're an assistant
professor up for tenure and if you don't
get tenure,
you have no career.
I don't blame them.
I get it.
That's what I've done too.
I police myself because you have to to
stay in the game.
If you have tenure,
lifetime appointment,
you're a senior professor.
You make the decisions there on
curriculum,
hiring and firing and tenure.
The faculty make those decisions and you
don't challenge these crazy ideas in any
way.
Or if you police yourself,
you stop yourself from saying things
that you think are right that you
believe in.
You're a coward.
I'm sorry.
Those people are cowards.
I've seen it.
It's just overrun by cowards.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I mean this.
They are very though.
So here's the thing.
I can't prove this.
This is just,
I'm just saying this is,
this is my belief,
but I think it's pretty well informed
because I've been around these people a
long time and in part I share this,
the,
I think the worst fear of all those
people is being called a or a sexist
publicly.
I think that is their version of being
in a cave,
crawling on their bellies in the pitch
black.
I think that's their worst.
Fear it and for not.
It's not entirely irrational,
right?
You can,
you know,
you will be publicly shamed.
You will.
The whole campus will think you're a
racist even if you're not.
Um,
it might even make the media and then
pump and then the whole world thinks
you're a racist.
For a minute,
but you're not going to lose your job if
you have tenure,
you know,
a year,
unless you actually did say it did say
something that's truly racist.
Um,
it's just cowardice.
I think that's what we need.
We need those professors,
the ones with the power and I'm talking
about they have absolute power on these
campuses,
right?
These aren't even like politicians.
You have to go up for a vote.
They,
they're there forever unless they
basically killed somebody,
you know,
they need to stand up now.
People like Jordan Peterson and I have
major differences with him on sort of
the content of his ideas.
Uh,
not about academia but on academia.
He's right completely and I'm totally in
solidarity with him,
what they did to him and what they're
doing to him.
Uh,
we need more people like him standing up
and saying,
no,
I'm going to say what I want in my
classrooms and on twitter and in because
that's.
People have been punished for that too.
Was it trying to get him to stop doing
is youtube black rhino,
which is fascinating because they're
very measured.
Their long form.
He gets to expand on his thoughts as
much as he likes.
He's very,
very informed.
I again,
I,
I have major disagree.
What is the disagreement?
Disagreements with him on gender and
postmodernism.
I think he's completely off,
but you know how solid and so,
so he,
and I know you agree with him on this.
I think,
well maybe,
I don't know.
I'm not sure,
but you know,
it's this idea that there just are two
genders.
That's it.
And they're good.
Okay.
He seems to think that I'm.
So.
I think there's a spectrum of humans in
every single aspect of being a person I
should say.
I heard your conversation with them and
I could see,
and this was interesting,
it was exciting because I could actually
see you moving in a direction that I
found to be much more interesting than
his,
which is closer to mine,
which is,
yeah,
that it.
This,
it's fluid feminine men.
There's masculine women there.
Thailand,
in fact.
Speeding.
Here we go.
Merging all these topics together.
One of the top Moitai fighters recently,
I don't know if she's still fighting,
is a ladyboy in Thailand.
Well,
once she became,
once you got the operation,
her performance dropped off pretty
radical.
Sure.
But that's just the lack of a Felon Fox,
so I agree with you there.
So here's the thing.
Okay.
That's a different story.
I totally agree with you on that
particular thing.
Right?
Whether she should have been allowed to
fight.
Well,
it's not that she should have been
allowed to fight.
I think she should be allowed to fight
women as long as the women know that she
used to be a man.
That's fine.
Tim was,
for the first two fights,
she didn't disclose it because she said
it was a medical procedure
and she didn't have to give up the
personal details of her medical
procedure.
I say,
that's bullshit,
right?
I say,
well,
you're dealing with a chromosomal issue.
You're dealing with the fact that you
have a different bone structure.
Yes.
Different mechanical advantages and 30
years of testosterone in your body.
It's just not the same.
Exactly,
but as long as someone knows.
Look,
I'm fine with drained Germain de
Randamie.
She knocked out a man.
I don't know if you ever saw this,
but she's.
She's just,
she's not choose to fucking bad ass.
Fucking bad ass.
I mean,
I don't know if she's taking anything in
her entire career.
It would just be pure speculation.
She doesn't look like she has.
That doesn't mean anything either.
Right?
Right.
But she's so fucking bad ass and so
tactical and so tough.
I know she's fought men,
but she knew there were a man going in.
She made a decision just like,
I think you should be allowed to sky
dive,
just like I think you should be allowed
to ride bulls.
I don't think it's smart,
but you should be able to do whatever
the fuck you want to do.
I'm all for freedom of expression of
participation in any sort of dangerous
activity.
My issue 100 percent was that people
were trying to pretend that there's no
advantage whatsoever and that's crazy.
That's silly.
So the thing is what they're.
So within that framework,
within the rules we are operating in,
right?
Whether it's in fighting or whether it's
in this particular society and wrestling
girl and read all about that too.
Right?
Exactly.
So those are,
that's a particular route you're,
you are agreeing to play a particular
game,
right?
Right.
And you're just breaking the rules.
That's all.
I mean you have,
you have soil body.
Well they're letting them break the
rules.
The rules are not and I think a lot of
it is people worried about being called
transphobic or homophobic or in any way
prejudice where they're allowing certain
people to compete in these.
Like this woman in Australia,
the Trans Woman in Australia that just
broke all these world records in
weightlifting because she was a fucking
man or a whole life and all of a sudden
became a woman.
It's just killing everybody.
And then there's the lifting,
the runners and I think they're from
Kenya or South Africa.
No,
the one from South Africa to color.
I forget her name,
but what do you mean?
The one that's like a Hermaphrodite who
will.
I don't know what she is,
but she's broken every record by like,
you know,
huge insane amounts and thinks she's
just a woman with an abnormally large
amount of testosterone.
I think they've actually done
chromosomal tests.
I don't know,
when I saw her in the Olympics,
I just jumped out at me.
I just pulled that up because I'm pretty
sure that that woman actually has been
tested and then there was a real issue
behind it and she felt terrible about it
because it was just the way she was
born.
Really?
Yeah.
Well,
again,
a spectrum.
Yeah,
I cooked.
There's men.
What a tremendous amounts of
testosterone.
There's men that have like almost none.
That's actually the major point we need
to talk about.
You're totally on the right track there.
I totally agree with that.
That's the most important thing,
which is that there's a spectrum,
right?
And so to say that there are that 50
percent of the world is male and 50
percent is female nonsense or men and
men are right.
That's say,
I say to my students,
I say,
okay,
there's 7 billion people in the world.
Okay.
Imagine in your mind lining all of them
up,
you know,
naked in front of you.
How many sections do
you see?
Right?
This is what I want you to do is get a
picture of Yoel Romero and put it next
to a picture of Andy Dick.
Tell me they're the same thing.
Telling me this is even.
They're both men.
Tell me it's even.
It's nonsense.
I mean,
right.
It's chaos.
I've,
you know,
it's like,
have you ever heard a guy on the
streets?
They,
man,
that's a lot of woman.
Yes.
Well that suggests there are women who
are less women to them.
Exactly.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
There's a spectrum and spectrum and
sizes mean.
That's what I was to ask you this.
Okay.
So let's push a little further.
Okay,
so,
so far you're doing very well in your
eyes.
Some people are screaming at their
fucking computer.
Believe me.
I know.
I'm going almost.
So that's.
Well,
no,
I think you already are.
I think you already went all the way
actually.
I mean,
so what?
There's two things.
There's,
there's the Jordan Peterson view.
Hang on,
let me,
let me put it out there and let me.
Okay.
What I think is he saying,
which is that gender is fixed and
biologically determined.
I'm pretty sure he does believe that.
Okay.
That's what I would call sort of the
traditional conservative.
Conventional.
Those both men.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or you know what or like there's more
than two categories in the world.
Right.
And so Andy Dick would be one.
And where would you put me there mean
neither one of those guys are in the
middle there.
I'm neither.
One of them you will see the deal is
both of them can procreate with women.
They'll both met but,
but whole lot of tech people who are
called men cannot procreate with women a
whole lot.
What do you mean?
They've been trans women.
Trans men live.
They can't.
It doesn't work.
Oh,
so they don't develop sperm or Sophia?
Of course.
I really common.
Yeah.
Once you tested when you were trying to
get pregnant?
No,
I just knocked her up.
Dude.
Come on.
Maybe I wasn't.
But anyway,
it certainly wasn't in there.
And watch the fireworks.
Yeah,
see,
there you go.
So you're more of a man you've just
proven yet again.
He goes,
the woman,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
When you.
Yeah.
That's not a great picture.
It doesn't give you a sense of how it
look at the thighs and the bolts bulge.
Well,
three times as high as most women.
Whoa,
okay.
So reports leaked out.
That doesn't really mean anything.
I don't think she's ever really been
tested.
I believe she has.
See if she's been tested.
What does the test set,
but it leaked.
She was subjected to sex verification
test after she won the world
championships in Germany.
And what does it say?
Yellow results.
We're supposed to be confidential,
but reports leaked out that she had
testosterone levels three times as high
as most women.
Other intimate details,
better anatomy were also reported.
A Somalia became targeted Semenya
Semenya how brutal your first name is.
The purse party named his semen.
Seaman
became targeted with abuse on social
media,
but what does it say?
This is.
So is it saying that she's a
hermaphrodite because they were talking
to
about her.
This is the clitoral size me.
It's the equivalent of pretty much every
article written about trump by the New
York Times.
Well,
you know,
a,
a report was leaked by,
you know,
senior officials said,
where's the actual evidence of any of
this stuff?
I don't see it.
Yeah.
What does it,
it doesn't say anything.
So she passed the test.
Doesn't matter.
He must have passed the test.
Here's the thing.
I think if I recall,
if I were a woman athlete,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I would want rules established.
it's like I would want rules established
defining the physical characteristics of
any of my potential opponents.
Right?
So it could be whatever bone density,
muscle mass,
you know,
testosterone levels,
you name it,
you,
you could probably speak to this better
than I could,
but I'm sure there's all sorts of ways
you could actually define that pretty
precisely.
And you can test those things and you
can say,
okay,
you get to be in this.
It's like weight classes and fighting.
It's no different really.
Right.
I mean,
you're not allowed to fight someone
who's 30 pounds lighter than you are.
And so you could do that in any sport,
you could say,
right.
If you're above a certain height or
above a certain weight or have this much
muscle,
are that much testosterone,
you're not allowed in this category.
There's nothing wrong with that.
There's nothing sexist about that.
There's nothing anti-trans about that.
It's just a different candidate,
but that's all that matters,
right?
That if that is the problem was that
Fallon Fox had,
as you said,
more muscle,
more testosterone,
all these physical characteristics that
were fundamentally different than all of
the other women fighting in that
category.
In that particular game.
That's all you gotta do.
Problem is that you can do damage to the
person and it's not as simple as playing
basketball against someone who had more
testosterone.
It's terrible to do that.
There's also like there's a type of
thinking that's involved in discussing
this were the you.
You have to follow a line of thinking.
If you don't follow line,
thank you're transphobic.
You're a hateful person,
you're a bigot,
and that line of thinking is not science
based.
It's just not.
When you.
When you talk to board certified
endocrinologist,
do they talk about Trans People?
One of the things that they talk about
is the fact that when you take estrogen,
it actually maintains bone densities,
the reason why they give estrogen to
women who have osteoporosis,
so this idea that your bone density
decreases when you go from being a man
to a woman.
It's bullshit.
You're taking testosterone.
Your bone density is going to stay the
same or get thicker,
but if you're taking estrogen,
your bone density is also going to
maintain.
It's going to help you maintain so when
you remove the body's ability to produce
testosterone its own.
There was a whole article and I'm bloody
elbow of MMA by this board,
certified endocrinologist,
Dr Ramona sick and which she did
different than everything else.
All these other articles is.
She's not a gender reassignment surgeon,
okay?
All these other people that are
commenting on this have a vested
interest in it being completely neutral.
There's all these people that are trans
people that are commenting on it and
they're doing it from a very biased
perspective because we're not talking
about mountain biking,
which there was a woman who used to be a
man who dominated mountain biking and it
became a giant issue with people.
They first supported her and then she
was winning by such enormous margins.
They were like,
well,
what the fuck?
Same as the woman in Australia.
That's the weightlifter.
This is different.
This is fighting.
And I think fighting Fox almost killed
that woman.
She beat the shit out of a few girls,
but then she lost Ashley,
Evan Smith who is a biological female,
you know,
so it's.
You can beat someone like that.
But again,
Ronda Rousey probably beat the fuck out
of most 135 pound men in the world that
she meets.
Of course,
you know,
it's just a matter of skill level.
It's no different than ped,
like banning pdds.
We want to do that same thing.
It's altering the body's chemistry,
its abilities.
Right?
And so you don't want to compete against
someone,
show us that difference or unless you
know,
right as you're saying,
and then you can or unless you're
allowed to do the same thing,
then it's all fair,
but you couldn't.
You would.
The woman would have to take
testosterone and balance it out and then
you'd have to find out how would you
balance out 30 years of my body
naturally producing testosterone,
increasing your ligaments strength and
conditioning attendant strength.
You also have,
there's mechanical advantages of male
hips are very different when it comes to
kicking.
When it comes to certain types of
movement.
Women's hips go out and then their legs
kind of come in at an angle and it's not
not the best for kicking.
It's not the best for a lot of different
activities.
Different.
So I would just say that a trans woman
is absolutely,
in my view,
a woman,
fine.
You know,
I've done.
That's their identity and I respect that
however they want to identify because
the category of woman,
as you said,
is so fluid,
you know,
let.
I'm not going to say there's any
absolute about that either that it can
change and it's,
you know,
comes from her ideas,
but still I respect that and I'll call
you a woman.
I'll treat you like a woman,
but that means we have to change the
sports,
right?
And we have to have just different
categories.
Instead of women's sports and man's
sports,
we need to have an woman and man
categories in those sports.
We need to have different categories
that are about people's physical
composition,
what you're made up of.
Right?
So it just like weight classes and pe
days.
There's no difference to me.
Well,
or there could be the argument that a
person,
a trans woman is a woman,
but when you're talking about athletic
competition,
you're talking about a very biological
thing.
I'm saying if you take.
You might have to say that someone has
to be a biological female to compete.
Again,
I'm saying take the gender out of the
sport,
right?
If you take that,
if you stopped calling these gender
names,
then it's,
then it's definitely not a trans issue.
It's just about what your body's made up
of.
So for instance,
adjust weight class Germane to random,
he is pro,
I don't know Rhonda Rousey more likely.
It's probably made just physically
more like closer to a man,
closer to Yoel Romero than Andy Dick.
How dare you.
She's going to find this and she's going
to find you.
Gosh,
I hope so.
If someone likes to be hit,
it really choked out real fast.
Um,
yeah.
So,
so that means I would just say,
you know,
there should be a category you know,
of in the sport,
you know,
for people who are made up of that
composition and that could be people
that the society identifies as men and
who are or who identify as women or
whatever.
Oh Man.
That's a,
that's a slippery slope.
Why?
There's a lot of work there because like
what,
I mean,
how would you define it and what
parameters would use bone density?
Well,
you know,
are a lot of African American women have
similar bone density to white males.
So does that mean you should be able to
fight black checks?
Uh,
maybe.
It depends,
right?
So,
well,
no,
actually the kind of aren't doing it up
the old man,
I'm not messing with that and we'll even
though she's like,
what,
60 years old,
she gets down to 50.
You could crush me.
Um,
no,
but I mean they are doing it.
In fact,
we just saw this with,
what's her name?
A caster Semenya.
But what are they doing with all this?
It's the thing about testosterone level.
What do they do?
Actually they mentioned her.
No,
there's,
there's a number for testosterone that
you have to be below,
right,
to,
to compete in that sport as a woman.
So that's,
that's what I'm talking about.
Just add more categories,
not just testosterone.
You have to have.
That's what this says.
Okay.
It says your testosterone goes above a
certain level.
You're not allowed to compete as a
woman.
So I'm saying have that category and add
more categories like that.
And don't call it women.
And men just say it's category x.
You get to compete in this category if
your testosterone,
androgens what they're saying,
but it's so ridiculously loose.
It's saying a female with Hypo Androgen
Ism who is recognized as a female in law
shall be eligible to compete and women's
competition in athletics provided that
she has androgen levels below the male
range,
like all you have to do is just be like
a couple notches below the male range,
which is way above,
but I'm saying that's all objectively
determined you can do that.
They're trying to get her to take
suppression medication or.
That's what I'm saying.
This is all proving my point.
These are objectively determine with
them making her tone it down.
We have numbers.
We say if you hit this number for this
category,
you don't get to compete here,
but this is so,
so rare.
I mean she has a disease essentially
where she produces too much to stop.
This would apply to trans people is what
I'm saying.
Right.
So if you.
But what it.
Because even so you're still dealing
with the mechanical advantages of the
male frame.
The wider shoulder,
especially when it comes to hitting.
We could do that too and we do it with
weight already.
Why not a height?
Sure.
Boy,
in fact,
a lot of work I thought about that will
look.
I'm sure you have to like in weight
classes,
right?
Like I have a huge advantage.
I always use it.
I'm six,
one,
one 65 and I've really long arms,
so like most the time
people can't get inside my job.
Like I just put it out there.
They can and it's just a thing,
but it's like I often feel like this
isn't really fair in a way,
you know,
I don't have to be as good as they are.
I can be looser and it's true for a lot
of fighters,
but once they get inside on you,
they have an advantage.
Like Mike Tyson used that advantage of
being 5:10 on a lot of fighters an
advantage.
I think he just was really good at
overcoming it.
Hm.
I think there's an in fighting and
having shorter arms and he did the lower
he did the peekaboo past the jab
maximize really well.
Really?
He did that thing where it's did rocky
Marciano and Danny,
he had a really good way of getting
inside of slipping the jab and moving
constantly until he was inside on you
and then he will crush you with this
huge left hook,
but once he's there,
he doesn't have an advantage on you.
He's just there and he's Mike Tyson,
but you don't think it's harder for a
guy with a long ass spider arms to punch
a guy who is in tight on you with short
arms and is throwing shots to the body
like Tyson.
So I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I think there's advantages as long as
you are physically competent.
There's advantages in particular
movements and positions to all sorts of
different body styles.
It's very true in Jujitsu guys with long
arms and long legs and digits.
You have massive advantages with chokes.
You guys can get Darcis and guillotines
and triangles easier,
but you can also get arm barred easier
because the mechanical advantages and
armbarring you.
There's,
there's,
there's some weird advantages to being
like a twosome are Paul Horez,
stocky short guy.
Here's basket.
How about basketball?
There you go.
Oh,
it's all advantages tall.
Right.
And in fact there are leagues,
not an.
Actually there might be professional
leagues which are,
you know,
six feet and under leagues.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
Many leads.
Many P,
this is very common because most people
are under six feet tall.
Right.
So who could never play in the NBA even
though they're amazing basketball
players,
but they just don't have the arm length
and they don't have the height and all
that.
That's interesting.
So we just need more divisions.
The UFC,
you should have like,
you know,
welter weight,
it should be,
there should be heights within it to was
only five nines.
There's a current.
Isaiah Thomas,
he's a good player for the number ones.
Fantastic.
He's the guys that are under six foot
though.
He's a great,
great player.
Around six foot.
They get listed higher to the cheat.
So interesting.
He's.
So.
He's sort of the exception that proves
the rule.
He's five nine,
but he's really successful.
Yeah.
He's five,
three,
five,
six or something like three,
three,
five,
three and dunked.
Spicy.
Did five.
No,
I'm pretty sure.
Mugs,
you'd pull it up.
Jamie.
Jamie is my wheelhouse and you're in
Jamie's wheelhouse in a big way,
right?
There's your mugs,
but I'm pretty sure he ducked muggsy.
Bogues.
He may not have been a super clean dunk,
but it was a dunk.
Let's see.
10 out.
Let's see if he dunked.
Let go with a video.
That's my life goal was to say pull it
up Jamie.
Okay.
This spot web was mugsy.
Does it have a video of him dunking?
I don't think so.
We've never seen it in my google.
Muggsy.
Bogues.
Yeah.
What does she do?
Muggsy.
Bogues dunk and he did it.
Google that crazy.
Muggsy.
Bogues dunk Jamie.
Number two on Google.
Let's say I got to watch this.
I've never,
ever seen this in my entire life.
Dude.
He just in a video game,
that's probably not real.
Yeah,
I know,
but he really did.
I promise you in Mba life is in my
memory,
is that it wasn't a clean,
super clean dunk,
but he did get the ball above the rim
with his hand on it.
We're going to get to the bottom of
this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
join,
you'll get to that place is pretty
essential if we don't solve this is a
failure of a podcast.
There's a big difference I think between
team sports where you know,
you could have an advantage of having a
spud webb or muggsy bogues very mobile
agile kind of guy who can set plays up
versus guy like Shaq,
big giant guy who can get in the way of
things and I think there's all sorts of
advantages and disadvantages of that
size when you're talking about
individuals against individuals.
That's where things get weird.
And then when you're talking about
combat sports,
that's where people have just.
There's some people that just have these
tremendous advantages.
Like,
you know,
Paul Daley is ridiculous power,
like almost unfair.
Like he hits guys and just obliterate.
Yeah.
But you know,
that's not just strength.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it's also,
it's also geometry.
Body geometry.
Yes.
Right.
Lot of skinny dudes like me have power
some.
Yeah,
a lot.
Yeah.
Right.
And a lot of big Tommy hearns was the
best example is a bunch of them,
but he's also like this wide and then
his waist is like this and this angle
just I've thought it's actually.
I've actually thought his shoulder with.
Yeah,
I think what I'm saying.
Yeah.
You get that slide.
So this,
the shoulders like that torque.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean it's more to swing.
Yeah.
That way.
Yeah,
for sure.
Wide shoulders,
uh,
rotate around the spine.
Yeah.
Oftentimes equate,
especially when they learn striking
sports at an early age.
They learn how to develop that snap and
fluidity.
Tenants to a lot of muscle bound.
Guys don't,
don't know.
So they do,
they have it.
I want you to go talk to Dana and get
this,
get this going.
And we,
we need a height,
uh,
divisions we need.
Um,
we need testosterone,
you know,
division to comp,
testosterone level,
division.
Going to have estrogen level divisions.
I think we're where are literally one
generation away from being able to use
crispr and all these new genetic
engineering tools to make people
whatever style of person you want.
I think you're going to be able to
develop six foot,
four super athletes that look like
Anthony Josh or Vitali Klitschko or
Vladimir Klitschko.
You're going to be able to make those
now what I would give for bionic knees,
right.
These are fucked up,
but never when they're not,
they're okay.
They're.
They're problematic,
but I can.
I can function fine,
but they could go out and anytime.
You know what I mean?
If you've never been worried about that,
he never had to worry.
Right.
Can you imagine?
Well,
if you could just reduce,
but I'm telling you what they were
talking about before the podcast,
what they're doing now with stem cells,
with soft tissue injuries.
It's tremendous.
I mean,
it's really amazing.
It's never happened before.
What they're able to do to people that
have meniscus injuries is literally
shoot stem cells in there and you've
regenerate meniscus tissue.
I mean,
that's just never happened before and I
think that this is baby steps.
I think what we're at right now is
really,
really young.
I don't think 20,
30 years from now because 20 years ago
they didn't really use it at all.
Twenty years from now,
I think it's going to be insane.
Got to be able to.
I mean,
they're regenerated a woman's bladder
using her skin tissue.
They built her a bladder.
She had bladder cancer.
They built her a bladder and then
reinstalled it in her body.
Now she has a functional bladder that
came out of her own body.
They're regenerated.
I think they're gonna be able to do that
with tendons and ligaments and all sorts
of tissue.
I believe it,
and hopefully this is really promising.
They're going to be able to do that with
brain tissue,
so people that have had brain injuries,
people that have had cte,
they're hopefully going to be able to
use some of these therapies to
regenerate brain tissue.
Wow.
Yes.
That's huge.
Neurogenesis is,
that's,
that's the promise land.
God bless him.
You know,
I don't know anything about science.
I'm just a complete idiot when it comes
to math and science.
But man,
just go for it.
And by the way,
as far as universities,
you know,
I'm,
I am the harshest critics of
universities generally,
but well,
mostly what I'm talking about it
actually the humanities and social
sciences when I do that,
what goes on in the biology building,
the chemistry building,
the physics building,
I don't know,
but I know that what comes out of them
is a better life for me and all of us,
they're making this stuff that you're
talking about and so go for it.
And so,
you know,
renegade universities,
not,
we're not gonna do no science.
We're going to let,
we're going to let Harvard and mit keep
going.
Have that guys,
you know,
because you're doing great stuff.
I have no critique of that as far as I
know.
There's nothing going on there that's
wrong,
but it's just the humanities and social
sciences that are utterly corrupt.
Well,
we got way off the track here with what
we were talking about initially was
Jordan Peterson.
I disagree with him when it comes to
gender and what you agree with him when
it comes to the suppression of
expression of professors and all the
people worried about being called racist
and sexist and anything else stifling
free speech.
So what he's facing is even worse than,
than what goes on in the United States
in a sense.
And that it's,
it's now legal persecution.
He is actually,
you know,
it's against the law to not use these
gender pronouns in your class.
Um,
which is that suppression of speech,
that suppression of Academic Freedom.
It's a complete violation of those
things.
In fact.
And that's totalitarian.
I mean there's nothing,
no two ways around it.
My uncle at Canada has these,
these laws,
right?
And they have a human rights commission,
I think it's called or human,
something conditioned human rights
council council.
And they do this body of people who sit
there and decide who should have a
website or not.
And my uncle is actually happened to him
about 10 years ago.
He was accused of being a Holocaust
denier because,
and I don't even know exactly what he
was saying on there,
but he's a Ukrainian and I think he was
sorta just defending these Ukrainians
who were accused of being Nazis during
the World War II.
I don't know.
It doesn't
matter.
Even if he were a holocaust denier,
he should have his website.
Right?
The Canadian.
You go to that url,
it's shut down.
In effect,
they put a banner now it says this is
now controlled by the Canadian
government or something.
Oh No.
Yeah,
no.
They have no free speech in Canada.
I mean there's no.
There's no sort of doctrine.
Legal or otherwise in Canada of free
speech is bad and that's what Jordan
Peterson's facing.
It's because he's Canadian.
This would not happen in the United
States until,
of course,
you know,
the sociologists take control and then
they will have these laws,
but we don't have them here,
so he actually could go to prison.
That's what's,
that's what's happening.
He could go to prison for not saying xer
in his class.
There was an article that vice published
that someone linked to me today about
this that I did not read yet because I
announced the Jordan is going to be
returning to the podcasts and someone
was saying that his interpretation of
these laws is greatly exaggerated.
See if you could find that.
It's a very recent advice article.
I'm pretty sure it's illegal and illegal
means you can go to prison.
Ultimately,
I don't think Jordan's wrong and I don't
think he would.
Exactly.
No,
no,
no.
I looked into this.
It's elite because that matters a lot to
me.
I am a hundred percent and solidarity
with him on that and he's completely
right that the state,
no one should be telling him to what to
say in his classroom and certainly
shouldn't be going to prison for it or
being threatened in any way legally.
He was just a fine a fine.
Right.
People don't understand this.
It's incredible how people don't
understand that everything the state
does is enforced by the threat of
ultimate violence.
Right?
So my mother even said this recently.
She said,
oh,
it doesn't it.
There is no violence with parking
tickets.
They just send you a fine.
I said,
Oh really?
So if you get the fine and you don't pay
it,
what happens?
Then we get another notice and another
notice,
right?
Mom and then another notice and then
finally what happens?
Korryn gaines is black woman in Maryland
a couple of years ago.
This is exactly what happened.
You got a bunch of traffic tickets and
she's refused to pay them and ultimately
what happened,
the Swat team came to her house and she
pulled a gun and they shot her in the
head.
That was over traffic fines.
Okay.
That's what happens.
That's what it means to make something
illegal at the end of the day,
for the.
For it to be meaningful as a law,
the state has to use lethal violence to
enforce it or the potential for lethal
while.
In other words,
if you don't pay your taxes,
even if it's $100 in taxes,
ultimately otherwise the law is
meaningless,
right?
They have to eat.
They have to put you in prison or kill
you.
Well,
that was what was most offensive about
that.
Sandra Bland case,
when you got to hear the interaction
between her and the cop,
she did nothing wrong and this cop is
dragging her out of the car and then
ultimately she died and they don't know
how she died and there's,
she was pissed off.
She talked back because he pulled her
over.
Fleet told her to put out her cigarette.
Right.
And she's like,
because she was being disrespectful.
Exactly.
She wasn't.
If you listen to the,
the,
the actual record.
No,
no.
She just wasn't following him to the
like
she wasn't treating him with respect
that he felt he deserved hold on there.
I think she was being disrespectful and
that's why she's my hero.
I mean,
because think she was disrespectful.
That's why she's a hero,
but I don't think she was because you
shouldn't be.
You shouldn't respect that.
I thought.
I mean it's dangerous and that's why
she's a martyr.
I'm not.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't recommend it to people.
I wouldn't tell my son to do that,
but he deserved no respect.
The law enforcing that law in that way,
treating her in that way,
in that moment was deserved.
No respect whatsoever and that's to me
why she's the hero,
not that she was a victim,
she was a victim,
but to me what was great about her was
that she said,
no,
I'm not gonna put up my cigarette and
why did you pull me over for this?
This is bullshit.
Well,
I mean,
you have no reason to pull me over and
do this to me right now.
I'm on my way to someplace.
I'm trying to get some.
Is she getting pulled over for.
I think it was a.
I think it was as it was a lighter.
So she like didn't turn.
I think it was a turn signal.
Okay.
It was something really trivial.
Well,
I don't think he has the right to tell
her to put out her cigarette.
So that's not a disrespectful thing.
He's overstepping his boundaries.
I need to do in your car smoking a
cigarette in her car.
They have the right,
they have the right and I think in some
municipalities the obligation because
you are supposed to.
Here's the thing where Joe,
I mean,
this is the other thing is this is the
thing that La rests upon.
It rests upon us respecting legal
authorities.
If we don't,
there ain't no law.
Yeah,
but there's no legal authority for you
to stop you from doing a lawful act like
if she has a cigarette lit in our car.
When she gets pulled over,
the cops says,
put your cigarette out.
What he's doing is just controlling her.
They don't think they give them
latitude.
They give the cops latitude in
determining who is obeying their orders
and not.
So if this could be.
I'm sure this yet,
I'm not defending this.
I'm saying this is the problem.
I'm saying that in court,
I would bet you anything he would say
that show that she wasn't listening to
me.
She wasn't obeying my orders.
I think he told her to put her hands on
the car or something and she had a
cigarette or enhance,
so she had to take the cigarette out of
her hand to do what he was asking.
In other words,
I'm saying that's all worthy of
disrespect.
I'm not defending it at all.
Right.
The other thing though about this,
and this is something I've been working
on lately and uh,
I've been doing some work with some
people at free think media about this,
but is I think,
and I've changed my mind about this.
This has been a new thing for me.
I have thought about race my whole life
basically really,
really hard.
And this is,
I've changed my mind about this when,
when things like that happen.
Sandra Bland,
Mike Brown,
Eric Garner,
even Walter Scott,
the guy who was shot in the back in
South Carolina.
What have you got where they planted the
Taser?
Well,
that's again,
hold on there.
So I like everyone in the country pretty
much saw those things and thought a,
that's horrific.
A and B,
that's racist.
Okay.
And that what people do overwhelmingly
is they focus on what they believe is
the racism of the cop,
the individual,
that that's what caused those cops to
shoot those guns in those moments.
I think that's a mistake for one thing.
We will never know why they chose to
shoot,
to pull the trigger in that moment.
We will never know that it was racist.
There's no way to prove that.
There's no way to demonstrate it.
Um,
and there's nothing we can do about it.
You can't.
What can you do to change people's ideas
about race or black people?
You can't.
Certainly not anytime soon what all
those cops were doing and all those
instances.
And this is why they got off.
They were following the law and they
were following police procedure which
actually obligated them to do,
to do those things.
So Walter Scott,
and believe me,
I was convinced that was a racist cop,
that that was clearly a bad killing and
it was a bad killing,
but not for the reasons that people are
talking about.
I have no way to know whether that cop
was racist and that's why he did that.
But if we do know and people have done
work on this,
that he is very reasonable to assume
that he was doing in that moment what he
was obligated to do by law,
which is if you look at the video
carefully,
he very well could have thought that
Scott was still holding his taser
because Scott grabbed the Taser and then
dropped it immediately.
But if you look at where the cop is
looking,
he may not have seen that we're talking
about different thing then because I'm
talking about the cop that shot the guy
and then drop the Taser near his body.
We're talking about the same thing.
Now,
here's what I grabbed the Taser that
here's what happened.
Okay.
Yeah.
Walter Scott grabs his taser.
He grabbed the cops,
Taser crab footage,
just ran,
pulled,
not pulled the Taser out of his holster
and had it for a second and then,
and then started to run.
And as he's turning to run,
he drops it immediately and he's running
away and it gets,
you know,
a good whatever,
10,
20 yards away and the cop shoots him in
the back.
Okay.
So according to South Carolina police
procedure and I,
and according to the Supreme Court
decisions,
uh,
the cop not only was had the right,
but the obligation to use lethal force
because he could have believed in that
moment that Scott still held the Taser
in his hand.
If a person takes a police officer's
weapon,
police are obligated to use lethal force
to stop them.
So if you look,
you just have to.
There's a,
there's a video,
there's a documentary about this.
It's called frame.
I forget the number,
I think it's three 94.
You might be able to find it,
Jamie.
But um,
and it's plausible.
It's not definite,
but this is what happened.
But it is plausible if you look the way
the,
where the cop was looking,
he may not have seen that,
that the Taser was on the ground.
I'm super confused because I thought
that the cough drop,
hold on,
I'm not venting.
Listen,
let me finish.
So he's like,
so Scott running away 20 yard shots in
the back.
Then the cop walks over to him during
that time.
He does see that the tasers on the
ground next to him,
next to the cop,
he picks up the Taser.
The cop does walks over and drops it on
the ground next to Scott momentarily and
then picks it back up.
Uh,
so who knows what was going on there.
He,
he may have been insured,
he may have been trying to cover himself
in that moment,
but actually he didn't need to that cop.
You know what happened with that trial?
It's a hung jury.
He's,
he's free because of this,
because I'm sure we don't know for sure,
but I know that this was the argument
made by by the cops lawyer,
was that it is totally reasonable to
assume that he believed he was.
He had reason to shoot him legally.
So that's one part of that story,
right?
Which is that the law is the problem.
Okay.
Not The cops stopped focusing on that
copy.
You'll never find out.
You'll never be able to prove that he
did it because he's a racist.
And even if we did,
what's that going to give two?
What's that going to get us?
That's not going to save anybody the
next time this happens.
Right,
but what will save people's.
If we,
if we change those laws,
here's the worst law that really made
the whole thing happened in the first
place that no one's talking about.
The whole thing started when Scott was
driving through North Charleston,
right?
The Cop,
I think it was a suspended license plate
or something,
or a tail light tail light.
I think it was taillight.
Something trivial pulls them over.
At that time,
Scott was in arrears on child support
payments.
Right,
and you go to.
Here we go.
You go to prison if you.
If you get behind on your child support
payments,
and he had been,
I think put in jail a few times in his
life for this.
You get put in prison and there's a
whole bunch of men right now as we speak
in prison for that very reason,
and these child support payments by the
way,
are set by judges often in a system that
read that massively favors the women,
the mothers.
That whole system.
You've never been divorced,
right?
I have.
You know,
as soon as you enter it,
you see right away that the whole thing
is stacked against us and it's,
this is,
you know,
it's just,
you look into it,
if you don't believe me,
you have to basically nine friends and I
went through the mildest divorce.
I mean my ex wife was as,
as easy on me as you could be,
but nonetheless I ended up paying a lot
more child support than she really
deserved and very.
But not a lot.
I mean,
but it was a lot of men.
Oh.
In fact,
you do have a friend just happened to I
think,
right?
Yeah.
You go into these courtrooms and it's
basically down to a judge as to a friend
who has to pay alimony for the rest of
his life.
Yeah.
He was married for 12 years.
He's been divorced for 14.
He still has to pay his ex wife.
He's married to a new woman.
He has a new family.
He didn't even have kids with.
This woman has to pay her forever.
Yeah,
forever.
Imagine if.
Imagine if they had kids.
He fucked her so hard.
She can't work anymore forever.
How about that?
That's a crazy little lot to say about
that,
but yeah.
Uh,
but uh,
that's a crazy law when they have
windows kids involved.
Right?
Forget about it.
That's a very sexist law by the way,
because that law is implying that this
woman is incapable of making it on her.
Thank you.
By
definition,
it's antifeminist.
Yes.
It's antifeminist and it's sexist and
it's patriarchal.
It's totally patriarchal.
Women who support it,
they're supporting it because they don't
like men.
I mean that literally what it is,
what it is,
who knows?
I don't know about listening.
If you're supporting a woman,
never having to work again because she
married a guy for a certain amount of
time,
like relationships come and go.
People get tired of each other.
People have the right to change.
You shouldn't be financially obligated
to take care of someone for the rest of
their life just because you were married
at one point in time.
That's crazy.
Completely agree with you.
Especially in today's Day and age where
my friend is 54,
I think he is now.
He could live to be 100,
so what the fuck?
He's got to pay for her for another 46
years.
That's insanity.
Phenomenal.
Yeah,
but again,
when you that I agree with you
completely,
but what you said just then about it
being sexist,
it is.
That's a radical concept that hasn't
even,
I think registered with most people and
if many people heard it,
they would think you are a sexist
yourself for saying it,
but you know what?
It is inescapable that that's what's
going on.
That sexism against men is very common.
It's sexism against women too.
That's what we're also sending them.
That's the radical part of this,
right?
It's actually patriarchal in the most
fundamental sense,
which is that the court is saying that
the man should be the provider.
I'm going to tell you a story.
There's a woman in Florida who is a bit
in my act and I'm doing now.
It's a true story.
There's a woman in Florida was a cop.
She was 25 years old.
She pretended to be a high school
student and she's attractive woman,
made friends with this boy.
He thought it was his girlfriend and she
talked him into selling her pot and then
she arrested him.
That only works when you have a 17 year
old boy and a 25 year old woman.
If you had a 25 year old man throwing
dick,
your 17 year old daughter,
and then he gets her to sell him pot and
then he arrests her.
There would be people lining the fucking
street with torches to kill that guy,
but people are sexist against boys.
They feel that boys should just keep it
in his pants,
that boys should know better and you
know as well as I know when you're 17
years old,
you are baffled bag of hormones with a
boner just running through the world
trying to figure out what the fuck's
going on and you're 12 months away from
being an adult.
It's chaos.
It's craziness to end to think that this
young boy should be able to think
clearly in that moment while there's 25
year old woman has manipulating them is
insane,
but they allowed it and this kid has a
felony on his fucking record right now.
Yup.
This is,
this is the root of the issue with
feminism.
That is current feminism in its current
incarnation.
I am a feminist by the way.
How dare you can define the lead.
Now's her.
Uh,
but I will just be an egalitarian.
Yeah.
So.
Well,
that's okay.
I'm not that either.
I'm not a nigger Alterian,
but um,
you're not.
No.
Oh,
hold on.
Too many topics.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
we go off a lot of branches here and I
love it.
Um,
where was I going?
Oh,
this family.
What you did was you identified,
and I think actually we,
I talked about this the first time I was
here,
which is,
that know this is what's,
to me at the heart of this is the
appalling irony at the heart of
contemporary feminism as practiced by
self-defined feminists.
Okay.
Many,
not all guys.
I'm not generally,
I'm not saying all feminists are like
this,
but I'd say it's certainly,
it's the dominant strain right now,
which is that it is at its heart
patriarchal,
which it treats women as vulnerable,
weak,
powerless,
or incapable of making their own way in
this world.
And it treats men as the not just forget
about the men,
forget about how they treat men.
It's how they treat women.
That's sexist.
It says that they need protection from
the state,
which is run by usually men,
but it's also this other institution or
you know,
college presidents need to protect these
women from 19 year old boys.
You want to have sex with them.
Same thing.
They're constantly calling for women to
be protected by these institutions.
The state by men,
it is patriarchal and sexist right at
the,
at the heart of it.
And same thing with family court and
divorce law and all that stuff.
That's how they get treated.
They get treated like they're the ones
who need to be taken care of by a man.
It is.
It's like 19 fifties.
Sexism.
It's like madmen sexism.
That's what.
That's what most feminists are calling
for now.
Well,
I disagree when you're talking about
child rearing because I think that
child support is,
should be absolutely mandatory and it's
very important.
And if a woman is the only one raising
the kids on her own,
not only does she need the money for
food and housing,
but also probably for someone to babysit
her kids.
There's a lot of factors involved and
totally agree.
And if the man's not in the scene like
yeah,
he owes money for sure.
He has a responsibility.
And as a father,
at the very least that's what you should
be doing is contributing financially.
I totally agree.
I'm not opposed to paying child support.
Alimony.
Alimony is weird.
Yeah,
that makes no sense at all.
It's weird.
Well,
it's.
I don't think it's a bad thing if
someone like say,
how about this?
Say let's turn around.
Say you had a wife who was wealthy and
she was taking care of you while you're
going through school and she promised
that she was going to fund you all the
way through your phd program.
She was going to give you money so you
didn't have to worry about anything but
your education.
And then once you got out then you guys
could share income.
But somewhere along the way,
she decided she was done with you and
then you're fucked.
But during the middle of this program
that you have to pay for,
I don't think it's unreasonable to say
that she should give you until you could
figure your own system out so you don't
have to quit your phd program and go get
a job somewhere and get an apartment and
a car.
I don't think that's.
That's it.
I don't think that's unreasonable.
What's unreasonable is saying that
because you guys were together for a
amount of time,
she has
to pay you for the rest of your life.
Sure.
That's insanity.
And that's current.
I agree.
That's real.
I agree that's a sexist.
But should that be legal though?
So that'd be legally enforced.
Should courts be deciding how long the
alimony is paid and that's.
I don't know.
How has that happened?
Like what?
What's the motivation behind that for
the courts to succumb to give in and
just explain it to you?
It's sexism,
it's patriarchy and the feminists are
playing along with it.
That's it.
It's this.
Yeah.
It's this idea that women can't make
words though,
isn't the courts,
aren't there a lot of men involved in
those courts do.
I mean,
why are they allowing all this stuff and
most of them think basically like
feminists or at least they.
They are expected to behave and make
decisions like feminist feminism has
become dominant in that way in our
culture going on for decades.
Laws have existed long before feminism
and so prevalent.
That's my point.
It went from sexism,
patriarchy,
those laws.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So feminism is basically continuing that
stuff in.
It's Nagy back on it.
And switching up the definition,
let me say really loud and clear.
There have always been feminists who
hate this stuff as much as you and I do.
Camille Paglia.
Okay.
And they have been loud and clear about
this for a long,
long time.
And I love them and they're my heroes
and I've learned from them.
This is,
I've learned these things from them.
Okay.
But the ones who really are powerful and
dominant in the media,
the ones we hear from the public
intellectuals,
the academics,
government leaders,
the people who end up in the White
House,
you know,
Obama's staff in hhs,
health and Human Services and the
Department of Education became very
clear to me that all these sexual
assault laws and rules that came out of
there,
they were,
they were coming right out of colleges
and they were really have that.
They were of the sort of college
feminist movement.
They were the ones who sent that letter
in 2011 that made it basically mandatory
for colleges to set up these kangaroo
courts for sexual abuse,
sexual assault cases.
All the nonsense.
You and I talked about a couple years
ago.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I go.
Anybody interested in review those or
earlier podcast about your college?
About oxide?
Yeah.
As many colleges.
But you know,
there's a whole backlash now,
right?
There's a huge.
It's all turning back and I knew it was
going to happen.
Now they are completely being decimated.
There's hundreds,
maybe even thousands of men who are
suing in court and many of them are
winning right now for good reason
because there was no due process because
they weren't allowed to,
you know,
ask questions.
That poor boy the mattress boy with that
girl put a mattress on her back and
drags around campus and then took her
graduation speech with a mattress.
They live.
Went on stage with a mattress.
I mean,
the whole thing was so fucking crazy.
Oh yeah.
My uh,
yeah.
There's this fantastic sex worker
activist named Christine Pereira,
who's in Vegas.
She said she tweeted something like,
when that happened,
he said,
fuck you,
mattress girl.
For those of us who have really been
raped,
you're a fucking disgrace.
She went off.
It was something like that.
Yeah.
And it was.
That girl seems pretty crazy.
That mattress girl.
Yeah.
That was an extreme
example of them boys suing that school
there also.
And many of them are winning and I don't
know what happened in those cases.
I don't even know what happened to
mattress girl for sure.
For sure.
I know that there's all kinds of
evidence that sure looks like it didn't
happen the way she said it.
Didn't know for sure and I never will.
We will never know.
You can't know,
but what we do know for absolute sure is
that there's been terrible or no due
process in those cases.
Right.
And so that's the problem.
I mean that basically the accuser gets
to win every time.
Imagine if that was our legal system
writ large.
Right.
Jo,
you stole a million dollars from
yesterday.
All right.
Put Him in jail.
That's basically what's happening.
Exactly.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it got so crazy that even rolling
stone printed a false rape case that
that gang rape case and Uva k
astonishing,
which is just how did a company that's
been in the journalism business,
as long as they've been,
how did they fuck that up?
Yeah.
That was.
That was the turning point.
I think when that came out that it was
completely made up.
I think since then it started to turn
something that's good that things like
that happen so that you realize why it's
important to have checks and balances
and that people.
It reaffirms this idea of real
journalism is important to have your
facts in order to have checks and double
check things and make sure you know what
the fuck you're printing.
I think it's good for society.
I think it's terrible for John Doe all
the John Doe's out there,
all those men who were accused and
expelled and had their names ruined and
their careers ruined.
College careers destroyed and all that
stuff,
right?
I think,
but yes,
you're also,
even if you're exonerated,
the emotional turmoil that you go
through,
there's no way they can reward you for
that.
There are compensate you for that
rather.
So that.
But that is part of that whole thing,
as I said before,
is part of this sort of ironic feminist
patriarchy ideology.
Right?
Which is,
you know,
we need protection.
We can't,
we can't because we can't say no to men.
We can't stop them by saying,
no,
we need,
you know,
w w we need help.
Just there,
we need to,
we need the college president to save us
or the cops or someone.
It's,
it's an incredible,
um,
well then there's this also this thing
where two people are drinking and if two
people are drinking,
the girl is getting raped,
but there you go.
Same thing guys not getting ready
because women are incapable of
controlling themselves when they're
drunk.
Sexist as hell.
Exactly.
Because the man's drunk too,
but it doesn't.
Somehow or another,
it doesn't matter.
Even if they're both like sending texts
back and forth.
Do you have condoms?
Like the Occidental case,
patriarchal women,
our children,
their daughters going to be taken care
of by dad.
And the sons are men.
Yeah.
Even though they're just same age.
And they're boys.
Yeah.
They have full agency.
And the women.
The women are daughters.
Yeah,
it is sexist.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so okay.
Gender,
Jordan Peterson.
I'm,
so,
I'm completely absolutely with him.
You know,
when it comes to that,
when it comes to policing of language
and.
But he,
as I said,
I,
I could be wrong about this,
but it sounded to me and I've listened
to him on your show and I've listed them
elsewhere and a lot of people have
pointed him to me and vice versa because
they think we agree on these things and
we don't,
which is that he thinks seems to me that
gender is biologically determined that
there are two genders,
they're fixed in nature and that's the
end of that discussion off he's ever
said that.
And I don't,
I really don't think he has.
Yeah.
Well thank you.
Said that when it comes to gender
identity,
that he doesn't believe that we need
more pronouns and so he thinks it's just
wrong.
If you think you're a woman when you
were born with a penis,
it's just by.
It's just sort of absolutely wrong.
I think you would have to find him
saying that before.
I'm really glad to hear you say that
because I wasn't sure where you stood on
that.
No,
I mean fuck man,
that's a big deal.
I think that's a big deal.
It can get super weird when.
Okay.
How about Rachel Dolezal she identifies
as being black?
Yeah.
Let's use transracial.
How do you feel about that?
I think she's correct.
Not,
no,
hang on,
let me,
uh,
let me tell you what correct means.
They're not in a,
not in an absolute way,
right?
Not a scientific objective way,
but it's just as true as anything else.
Meaning that because so race and here's
where a,
here's,
here comes Sam Harris now and I'm sure
Jordan Peterson's in this boat to buy.
No,
Sam Harris's,
because I just heard him talking about
this with Charles Murray.
He believes there's,
there are races of people.
He thinks that race is a real thing.
He's,
he's definitely subtle about it.
Nuanced.
He says,
you know,
it's the divisions between races in the
lines are blurry and it,
you know,
but he believes there's a biological
basis to race.
He's very clear about that and that is
to me,
absurd and completely unscientific and
it's easily disprovable by according to
his own standards and by scientific
standards.
But you see a black guy from Kenya,
you see a white guy,
a Chinese guy from China.
What's the difference?
No difference.
So here's,
here's the answer you tell me.
Right?
Which is that.
So historically,
the differences between them have
changed that we people,
human beings have said different things
have created different categories and
filled those categories with different
characteristics over the centuries.
Those have changed constantly.
Right?
And my first time I was on here,
we had a long discussion about what's in
my book renegade history on immigrants,
the Irish and the Italians and the Jews.
When they got here to the United States
here and in Europe,
they were largely considered to be
negroes.
Right?
Right.
And now there is.
Why does anybody.
Right.
So what are they at that time in the
early 20th century,
it was not like when I say common
belief,
I mean it was taught in schools.
The following taught at
the following that Europeans were made
up of three distinct races.
There were the nordics and northern
Europe,
the Alpines in central Europe and the
Mediterranean and in southern Europe.
And they were very different
biologically.
The nordics where rational,
intelligent,
disciplined.
They were the ones who made
civilization.
They should run the country.
The alpines we're okay there could be
decent farmers,
but they're never going to do Algebra
and they certainly can't run a
government.
The mediterraneans were basically either
like negroes are really close and
therefore should be slaves or just
peasants.
That's why people,
you know it.
You're telling me you're talking about a
long time ago.
No,
we're talking about a hundred years ago,
which historically holding your breath,
but you know,
you love ancient history.
I mean if you look at the whole sweep of
human history,
that's five minutes ago,
right?
It is.
But it's still a long time in terms of
how we address it today,
but it will really address it today.
If you're looking at it.
Someone from China.
Oh,
you're looking at a dark black man from
Kenya.
Yeah.
There's something different about them.
Do you think it's just melanin?
Sure.
That's the horse.
There's something different about them,
the many different things.
Where do you draw the line about around
races though,
right?
So look at all the people in Kenya.
Okay.
Which ones are Kenyans and which ones
are they all Kenyans and what makes them
Kenyan or are they all Africans?
Well,
you know,
you can do the all black right passed on
someone and find out where their origins
are.
You can find out how much Irish you have
in you so much.
South African,
you can me.
You can do all that.
You can go all the way back to your
family lineage through jeans.
I get that total.
If you want to go all the way back.
We're all African.
Sure.
Well there you go.
That's another way to disprove this
whole thing.
Right?
Right.
But it's disproving it because we in
these proving it,
sorry,
that's a bad word to use.
Here it is calling it out as a fiction,
as a social construct,
which is that these lines have been
drawn all the time in all kinds of
different ways over the centuries by
human beings who just look at all the
people in the world.
They line up the 7 billion people,
right in their mind and they draw lines
is say,
oh,
these people over here,
this side,
those are the negroes.
And over here,
these are the mongoloid.
And over here these asiatics and over
here,
these are the nordics.
And over here the areas and the Jews and
those change all the time.
But these are just categories we invent,
right?
So who's black?
Jimi Hendrix,
black.
Well,
Jimi Hendrix has a mixed background,
right?
I mean it wasn't his mother white.
What's his race?
Is he black or white?
It's a good question.
There you go.
Got It.
A lot in them.
But.
So,
but there's a big difference between
someone like Jimmy Hendrix and someone
that is like very,
very dark,
comes from a specific part of the world
where everyone around them is very,
very dark.
Let's do that,
are very obvious and repeatable
characteristics.
Let's do that.
So Congo,
these come from Chicago,
okay?
The people there,
they're pygmies actually immigrants.
And even the staff room,
you know what we can do?
West Africans were slaves were the west
where the western slaves,
American slaves come from.
Um,
and just across the continent,
not even that far away.
You know,
there's Somalia,
Somalians look like,
right?
Yeah.
And Ethiopians,
right.
You think about them and how they look
and think about how the,
uh,
west West Africans look.
Are they the same race will very,
very,
very characteristic,
very dark Somali.
Somalis looked different than everybody
clearly.
Right.
You know,
as Somali immediately,
right?
Same continent,
same pigmentation basically.
Yeah.
Other facial structured,
very different.
Why are they black?
Why are they the same race?
Is the question at the same race or.
I mean what I'm saying about Somalians,
like would you,
would you,
would you consider Somalians the same as
like Ethiopians or as the same as
Egyptian.
My thing is also Africa.
My thing is let's get rid of these
categories.
There is,
these are all silly made up categories.
There's no reason to.
They're all arbitrary.
Okay.
Lines have been drawn between groups of
people arbitrarily over the centuries,
but what you see,
you're arguing against something that
Sam Harris said.
So what did Sam Harris say specifically?
Not just him.
It's a lot of people,
but yeah.
So you don't agree that there is any
race at all?
I'm just saying it's a fiction.
It's made,
right?
It's just a.
it's like is it a fiction or is it a
way?
We're trying to define the variations
between human groups because there are
variations.
So that's definitely what it's been
about.
That's definitely been the motivation.
Right.
And think about what the consequences
have been.
Okay.
But it's never been good just because
there's never glances for variations or
recognizing variations doesn't mean you
should stop recognizing actual
variations,
but then you make.
But they always make claims right after
that.
Like it doesn't have to what Sam Harris
is Straw man,
isn't it?
I mean did you don't have to make a
claim that Chinese people are different
because they look different,
but then it's just,
well this is what a Chinese person
generally they have these very stringent
characteristics.
They don't have blonde hair,
they don't have blue eyes.
I'm not tall and skinny.
They look like Chinese.
Sure.
But then again,
Chinese people all look the same.
I mean there's to say that,
right?
But again,
with a clear characteristics,
the difference between a Chinese person
and a black person is very clear.
Uh,
uh,
not really well and not always Kenyan.
So lives in Kenya who was born and
raised multiple generations deep and
their parents are canyon,
their grandparents at Kenyon.
There's a very big difference between
them and someone who lives in Shanghai.
Yeah.
But who was born in Shanghai?
They're parents were born in Shanghai.
They'd go all the way back.
Many,
many generations of being pure Chinese.
Right?
But there are infinite variations even
among people who have lived only in
Shanghai,
but what do you want to call the
variations?
Nothing but,
but,
but you're talking about something
that's clearly
or you just ignore it.
I would say that there's,
of course,
there are genes that run in families and
I completely agree that,
you know,
genes determine in large part how we
look.
Fine.
So you can certainly say this person is
likely because of their genes connected
to that person,
last generation to that generation,
to this,
you know,
and his family lineage.
Sure.
Well,
what does that give you?
I don't know.
Nothing.
I mean it's.
The thing is that people have taken that
and they've said,
oh,
well these particular characteristics
are human beings.
We are talking about complexity and
human beings at the beginning of this.
Right?
People are infinitely complex.
Okay.
So the thing is,
what people have done historically is
they've just picked certain
characteristics among people and said,
oh,
that is what determines your race is the
issue.
The word race is maybe the issue.
Like there are obvious physical
characteristics.
The difference between someone who is a
mon goal versus someone who,
uh,
is a Brazilian versus someone who is.
There's some pretty obvious physical
characteristics for geographic areas.
What would you agree like,
or common physical characteristics for
some geographic areas?
Or You could say on average people in
China are shorter than people in
Polynesia.
Well,
here's the place where you could do it.
Canada,
like,
try to find a Canadian.
Like you don't know what a Canadian
looks like.
They could be English,
they could be American,
they could was trying to entertain.
You're your strongest argument.
Okay.
So like China,
right?
You can certainly say that people in
China are on average,
on average,
shorter than people in Polynesia.
Right?
Will they look different?
Whatever.
That's one way in which they look
different.
Right.
Facial talking about physiognomy facial
feature.
That bone structure.
Polynesians find to be like really
stout.
I suppose you could say,
you know,
the,
the width of their eyes is narrower or
whatever on average and whatever.
Sure.
Okay.
So what is it?
I mean,
what did we.
Okay.
So they,
they are likely to be in lineage from
that part of the world.
Fine.
That's cool.
I've got no problem with that.
But what else do you want to say?
The thing is,
Joe,
no one stops there.
They always go on to that.
They always go on from there and they
start to make all these other claims.
Oh well that race is really good at
math.
Their Iq is higher.
This is what actually Sam Harrison,
Charles Murray were just saying,
they can do the,
um,
they can do the coding for Google better
than,
than other people can,
whatever,
right?
They are more,
they are more scrupulous.
They smoked cigarettes more,
whatever it is,
you know,
they used to be accused of being a more
easily addicted to opium,
you name it,
right.
Things changed,
but that's the problem is that once you
start there,
people have used those differences for
other reasons almost always,
which are nefarious and injurious and
you have done terrible things to people.
Your problem is recognizing those
characteristics and those differences
and calling it a race and then attaching
all sorts of other claims to this
category.
Precisely.
Yeah.
That's exactly what Sam and Charles
Murray,
this is Charles Murray's thing,
although it's actually,
it's only a small part of his work and
he gets accused of it being central and
it's not.
But anyway,
he does still nonetheless believed this
and so to Sam Harris and so did other
people that there are differences in Iq
among races.
Okay.
Now on the surface level,
they are completely correct.
There's no question,
meaning that Iq scores among people that
we identify as African American have
been lower than among the people we
define as white American.
Totally true,
totally true,
and they are right that that is
suppressed,
that we are not allowed to even talk
about that data,
which is there and it's.
I have no problem with that.
I'm sure that's true.
Here's the thing though.
How do we define African American and
how do we define white first?
That's the first problem.
Those,
as you know,
definitions have changed over time,
so Jews used to be in the African
American group and Italians used to be
in the African American group was.
No,
no,
never,
never called African Americans.
They were,
they were called negroes.
Yes,
they were.
Shoes were called negroes.
A book written is in my book renegade
history in ninth in 1911,
there was a book written by a scholar
and this was one of many,
the title of which his name was Arthur
abernethy.
The title of which was the Jew is a
negro.
That's the title of it was common.
This is what pieces,
what year this is.
This is all through the late 19th and
early 20th centuries from about the 18
eighties when the Jews started coming
over and big numbers from the 18
eighties until the 19 forties.
This was,
I'm not,
I'm saying this is what was taught in
college classrooms that Jews were of a
different race and there was some
difference of opinion about whether they
were black or whether they were just
some other kind of inferior race,
but they certainly weren't white.
That was,
that was widely agreed upon until world
war two basically.
All right,
so how do we define African-american?
Is Jimi Hendrix,
African-american?
Does he,
you're talking to.
There's a big difference,
isn't there in the term African American
versus Negro,
right.
Because like it's the same thing.
It's just a different name for the same
category.
Yeah.
But it's from Africa.
They knew that these Jews weren't from
Africa.
So the.
So the one drop system continent,
I don't know.
They believe that they believe that the
genes and the right about this.
Right.
That the genes come from Florida.
Yeah,
so that's,
you know,
and they're bright but so do all of our
genes.
Right,
right.
Um,
so that was part of their claim and that
they were from,
you know,
part of Europe that was a bit closer to
Africanism when they said about Italians
in particular,
Sicilians,
right.
They're like,
Hey,
look where it is.
That's why these people are fucking all
the time and having babies.
True and are lazy and can't work and
fight in the bars and get drunk and.
Right,
right.
So,
so how do we define these terms?
What is white men that's totally
changed,
but how much of it is great?
They realize just how much of it is
cultural.
So there's that hold on and then,
and then I acu.
Well,
um,
I think it does measure something.
I think that's real.
I do,
I really do.
I think there was something called the g
factor,
which it,
it,
it tests,
it measures g factors,
this thing that was invented,
this concept,
it's a category,
but it's a real category in the world we
operate in,
which is your ability to do rational
thinking,
reasoning like math,
like writing scholarly essays,
you know,
I'm sure my g factor is higher sort of
than other people's,
although I'm terrible at math.
So that's yet another problematic
wrinkle for these people.
Um,
but yeah,
I,
I believe that Iq measures that stuff,
that kind of thing.
But is that what intelligence is and
only as clearly.
No,
no,
no.
A lot of variables that Iq test,
test,
write the tests,
all kinds of intelligence.
The test emotional intelligence.
Do they test the intelligence of Jimi
Hendrix?
Do you think he was great at Calculus?
I don't know.
I sort of doubt it.
Was He smart?
Was the intelligent clearly in different
ones.
Clever with a guitar,
that's for sure.
So then how do you define intelligence?
Activity is unquestionably some sort of
measurement or expression of
intelligence.
We separate that off though,
and we always have as a society,
we shouldn't.
That's why you don't do well unless
you're really,
really,
really good if you're just creative in
the way we define that and not
intelligent in the way Iq tests to find
it.
There's a.
So it's all problematic.
Um,
and it just,
it all it does is it just keeps raising
new questions that never has answers.
And so that the attempt to.
There's this thing that goes on where
certain people just need to keep finding
racial differences that are innate,
biological,
fixed that can't be changed.
And it's like,
first of all,
you've never done this because it's so
fluid and you're always,
you never really answering it.
And then what if you had,
did finally prove it?
What are we going to do with that
information?
You know,
we just recognize that there are
variables.
Like when you're talking about
Polynesian people,
are we talking about people from Tonga?
Very stout,
strong people,
samoans tend to be very stout,
strong people.
I mean,
that's a characteristic of actually a
positive characteristic that's
attributed to people from that area.
Do you ignore that?
Like how do you address that?
Of course not.
I would say that people from Polynesia
are more likely.
Men from Polynesia are more likely to be
offensive lineman in the NFL.
So your issue is calling it a itself.
Yeah.
And then attributing other things to it.
All I'm saying is guys from there tend
to be bigger.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
No doubt about it.
But so what?
That's the end of it.
Is there a part of the world where
people are generally thought to be dumb?
Yeah.
Africa,
the country that are that.
The continent we've been talking about
that,
that's the history of this country.
Does the history of Europe,
that's the history of the modern world
is the belief that people from Africa
are dumber than whites.
Well,
isn't the problem with that?
That Africa is also where the pyramids
were created.
That's what justified.
That's what justified slavery.
That's what justified colonialism.
That's what justifies has justified all
sorts of things.
Right.
So that's the problem here is that
these,
these attempts to define people by race
and by the way,
by gender,
have done nothing but terrible things.
Nothing but terrible things and you
can't do it anyway.
It's scientific bullshit.
It's total superstition is utterly
arbitrary.
The lines are always being redrawn by
the people who do this stuff,
so why are you still doing it guys?
Like it's where do you draw the Goddamn
line?
All the people in Africa are black.
Really?
Egyptians are the same race as people
from the Congo as the people from South
Africa as the people from Somalia.
I mean,
how are they the same race?
Because it's pigment skin pigment is
that the only determination will.
It's a fascinating thing when you call
people African Americans or call them a
Italian Americans because Italy is
actually a country.
Whereas Africa is a continent.
Fantastic.
It's,
it's weird to call people conduit,
right?
Because guess what?
Italy didn't even exist until the 19th
century.
I mean it was just a bunch of city
states until then and there was no such
thing as an Italian.
People who lived there didn't call
themselves.
It wasn't a concept,
it wasn't a name.
It was nothing.
And then they made it into this nation
state that they called Italy and then
ever since,
ever since then,
every sorry,
but every dipshit Italian American is
like really proud of that.
I'm Italian.
Well that dude that has no meaning
really in the deepest history at a some
weight meaning sure.
But they talk about it as if it's like
rooted in nature.
Like I love it.
They love being a part of that stupid
team.
Sopranos,
the Sopranos.
It's tribalism,
tribalism.
It is tribal and stupid.
And if it were just stupid,
I wouldn't care.
It's that.
It has,
as I said,
it just leads to bad stuff.
And it has historically,
let's go this popular opinion,
the,
the idea that there are no races.
Oh,
okay.
So,
you know,
Mr. Anti academic academic.
But this is where academics have
actually done their best work.
I think so,
and this is the second,
my second disagreement with Jordan
Peterson.
He thinks that all this stuff and
college campuses that's crazy is because
of postmodernism and he doesn't
understand postmodernism.
Uh,
the,
what's going on in college campuses as
people making all sorts of truth claims
about things like race and gender,
right?
I'm black,
therefore I will always be this,
that,
and the other thing.
You're white,
therefore you are this,
that,
and the other thing.
No matter what,
right?
That is actually old modernist
scientific racist thinking.
That's what these old racist geneticists
eugenesis thought back in the day.
It's amazing.
Again,
sjws are actually really,
really conservative and ultimately
racist.
The Social Justice Warriors folks,
your listeners must know that something,
I don't know the assume that was a
shorthand to use.
So postmodernism.
This is where Jordan Jordan Peterson
makes me want to like throw chairs when
he talks about,
um,
comes out of French philosophy,
uh,
in the 19 sixties and seventies and
eighties.
Michel Foucault is the most famous
example of a,
of a French postmodernist and he,
they get dumped on all the time,
but the central,
the central argument that was made by
food co and postmodernists was that none
of these things are biologically
determined that there is no natural
essence to anything.
That everything is a social construct,
which means that we now are free to
choose our own destiny as individuals.
Right?
Prior to that,
prior to the 19 sixties and seventies,
it was the dominant belief that if you
were born a woman,
you are going to be a wife and a mother,
and if you weren't,
you were doing something unnatural,
right?
That if you were black,
you could never be the head of a
business or the president,
right?
You could never do math,
whatever.
If you were white,
you know,
you should do all those things,
right?
Everybody's destiny was determined at
birth and everyone believed that.
Most people believe that.
Okay,
so postmodernist came along and said,
guess what?
You know,
what we found looking at history we
found is just what I said.
I just gave you the whole postmodern
argument right there.
We looked at history and we saw first of
all,
that all of these categories have
changed over time,
which tells us that they're just
inventions.
They're just inventions that get
reinvented all the time.
Okay?
And second of all,
they have served the purposes of ruling
elites because they get to put people in
their boxes and control them more
easily.
Right?
Oh,
those people over there,
those are black.
Therefore they should be our slaves.
So it's okay for us to have a mess.
Slaves,
those women over there,
we don't want them,
you know,
working for NASA.
So we will have a rule against women
Whatever it is,
right?
So postmodern has said,
none of this is biological.
None of this is inevitable.
You are now free to do what you want as
an individual.
It was a liberating moment.
It has become the dominant way of
thinking in academia.
And I have to say,
in my view,
it is the supreme achievement of
academics ever.
That's it.
But it's huge.
Huge.
So if you think about it,
look at how the world has changed
particularly in that in the United
States since then,
right?
We no longer generally have those ideas.
At least we don't operate as such.
So black people are allowed mostly into
places they weren't before.
Women are allowed very much so into
places they weren't allowed before.
All the whole world has changed and I
think principally from that idea,
so the trend,
that doesn't mean now the problem is
these social justice warriors so called
on campuses,
have used some of that language and
taking a shit on it.
So the Trans Movement,
for instance,
right?
That started from postmodernism.
That whole idea,
right,
is that,
you know,
if you were born with a penis,
you're a man and you should do x,
y,
and z with your life.
Right?
The Trans Movement needed that needed
postmodernism to make that intervention
and say,
no,
that's not true,
right?
You can actually be a woman because a
woman is an invention.
It's a social construct.
What Trans,
much of the Trans Movement now is doing,
which makes me so sad,
is that they're saying that I am
biologically essentially,
naturally,
you know,
in my core,
a woman,
no,
no one is,
no one is you can't change.
The whole point of this movement used to
be that you get to choose your gender or
choose not to be a gender.
You get to move around.
Your destiny is not determined for you
what the true.
A lot of the Trans Movement now is
doing.
This is a good word,
reifying.
They're making these ideas,
these abstractions real.
Again,
they're making these claims that are
similar to Sam Harris has claims and to
old racist claims and to old sexist
claims that if you're born in a
particular way,
biologically this is who you are,
right?
Because you've heard a lot of trans
people say this,
right?
I was born a woman.
That's where they often say,
what I'm saying is no one was born
anything.
You are losing me in a huge way.
Why you don't think that women,
that some women are born women and some
you don't think you're born a man.
No.
What are you born?
Why you men?
For all sorts of reasons,
for all sorts of reasons.
None of them being just decided.
We.
None of them being the x,
y chromosome.
You have testicles.
Then we went to and you have a penis.
None of them being the fact that you
generally gravitate towards male
activities like boxing,
kickboxing,
and we just.
We just went through this whole thing.
No,
you didn't.
Well,
Romero and Andy.
Dick.
Yeah,
but yeah,
they both men.
But you.
You.
You're a man yet,
right?
We're not talking about the broad
spectrum of masculine behavior.
We're talking about.
No one is born a man.
You're not born a man.
I'm not born.
And I'm saying,
no,
I think we're getting silly.
Hold on here.
I think it's the category of men becomes
meaningless.
Does it?
Yeah.
We just did this man.
No,
we didn't.
We didn't do well.
Romero and Andy Dick or put on category
jewelry at the ends of the spectrum and
I think they crossover the male female
lines do cross over when you get to that
Kenyan runner and Andy Dick.
Yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
It's so broad that it becomes,
to me pretty damn meaningless.
Well,
the numbers are incredibly small.
If those crossover marks,
you're talking about us.
Very,
very small percentage of the population.
Neither Andy Dick nor you'll ell Ramiro
are trans people,
right?
It might be.
They are so different though.
Physically in every way.
We both put them in this silly category
called,
man,
what the hell is that mean anymore?
And he has children.
He made them mind,
impregnated different women and got
babies from a lot of people called men
who don't and can't.
Can't.
Okay.
Yeah,
but that's rare.
They were rare in that way,
but it's pretty rare.
Not that rare.
Oh,
it's very rare.
Most most men,
when they have sex with a woman and they
put sperm in their body,
they can one maybe.
So that's one characteristic,
but hold on a second,
you're,
you're making it as if it's a really
common thing when you're talking about
like a small fraction of the men can't
make babies a incredibly small fraction.
So an incredibly vast majority of males
with the x,
y chromosome who have penises are
capable of impregnating a female with an
XX chromosome.
And the,
the male was born a male.
The female was born a female,
right?
So what do you mean?
But you aren't born a man or you aren't
born a female.
Right?
So there are many,
many characteristics,
right?
That we assigned to the categories.
Many of them.
That's one characteristic.
Okay,
so why?
Why is that characteristic in the man
category,
if in particular that there are some men
who don't share that character
characteristic,
but which ones don't you?
That's the aberration.
The aberrations,
the one operation to see these are all
images.
Get a woman pregnant.
They don't produce sperm.
You're talking about like very,
very rare cases.
Yeah,
same with center for race.
Same thing happens with sickle cell
anemia,
right?
This is what everybody invokes when they
want to claim that race is real.
Only black people get sickle cell
anemia.
Well guess what?
The numbers there are about the same as
the number of men who are infertile.
Why then are people with sickle cell
anemia?
Definitely black.
Why is that?
Definitely a black thing.
Same thing.
It's,
you know,
again,
why are we.
There's all these characteristics.
Why do we draw this line called man
around all those different people?
Well,
why don't we do it with animals?
When you have a male dog and a female
dog,
isn't there a male dog,
a female dog?
Eventually there's a male dog and he was
saying his inventions.
Now,
hold on,
so before you get,
but yeah,
no,
it is.
Of course it's not an invention.
One of them has a penis and testicles.
It's the thing we see.
We call it a penis.
Sure,
I get it.
No,
And that's the world I live in.
Absolutely.
So I operate in this way,
by the way,
by the way.
So if a dog penis world,
you and I would agree on all the things
in the world that are dogs right thing.
Okay,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna.
Walk around and be like,
oh no dude,
that's not a dog.
So with humans,
you're making a distinction that there
are certain feelings and the way you
interface with the world that may be
more or less masculine or feminine,
but it does apply to dogs.
My point here,
which is that we did draw a line right
in those.
There's this.
Do all dogs look alike?
My God,
there's a huge variation.
They're not talking about race though.
We're talking about gender,
right?
Either way,
it doesn't matter.
Same principle,
dobermans,
male Dobermans,
and female Dobermans,
right?
You can't.
If you go to buy a male Doberman and the
guy gives you a female dove men,
he goes,
oh,
but she identifies as being a male.
This.
It's just an invention,
man.
This is a male,
but she's a male.
You can't disrespect for by saying she's
not a male.
You would say,
that guy's crazy and you want your money
back.
Are there any two females who were
identical to female?
What?
Anything?
I mean,
if you have a really good breeder,
you can get pretty God damn close.
If you're talking about dog.
No,
no,
there's no.
There are no two into organisms that are
identical.
Certainly not down to the hair on
technicality,
but so you can still categorize them as
x,
y,
x chromosomes,
and I'm not saying we shouldn't
categorize anything ever because we must
do that to live in this world.
What are you saying?
What I am saying is we should probably
stop applying certain categories to
human beings in the ways we have done.
Like how so?
Because there were male and male and
female,
because there are certain inventions,
certain social constructs that do
nothing but bad things to do.
No good,
and their only social constructs like
race and gender.
Well,
tell me how race and gender.
I'm not worried about Doberman gender
definition.
Let's look at gender definition and tell
me how it's only bad.
Why is it only bad to find men as men
and women is women?
Because if you say it's,
it's.
It's about making the biological claim,
the bright,
the biological connection there will
making a definition which is saying a
guy who was born,
a guy who gravitates towards male
activities,
likes females,
all those things.
By saying that that's a man that this is
a born man and you're saying,
no,
no one is.
So if you're saying,
if those characteristics are naturally
determined than all,
all of us guys who don't do those things
are unnatural.
Which things are those all the time?
All the things that women,
whatever it is that you characterize as
being male,
that's so common with males and what is
being attracted to women really aging
and with women.
Have you heard of gay people?
Yes.
It's a small percentage of the
population of men.
Um,
is it one percent?
Is Four percent?
I mean,
it's certainly a lot of people,
isn't it?
It's a lot of people.
When you think about the 350 million
people we have living in America,
sure.
Take all them in.
Let's do this.
Take all the men who are straight up
homosexual.
Always have to hold on,
but you can classify them as gay men.
I know.
Hold on.
So just take that.
Whatever that is,
if it's one or two or five or 10
percent,
whatever it is,
I've only been homosexual hundred
percent.
Never been attracted to a woman period.
Okay?
Okay,
fine.
That's still a really significant,
significant number.
I'm not done.
Hang on.
Then.
Take the men who don't identify as
homosexual,
have had sex with women,
have been attracted to women,
but have fucked men prisoners.
Pretty Damn big number.
They're pretty dense.
Oh,
wait a minute.
How many guys do you think that are
attracted to women but still fuck men?
So Kinsey,
the Kinsey study.
Sure.
The 19 forties and fifties.
Found that it was,
I think 30 percent.
Yes.
Thirty percent of men.
Fuck man reached orgasm in a sexual
experience with another man.
Yes.
Thirty percent.
It was a very large number of was
hanging out with freaks.
Yup.
That's what I think.
There were different numbers for women
and men,
but they were both very significant.
Percentages vary.
Not Majority's,
but very significant percentage as well.
I have personally known.
I've personally known many men who you
would consider straight,
who identify as straight,
who have done something with men,
either given him a blow job,
gotten a blow job,
had full onset jerk each other off.
Jesus.
I'm surprised this is news to you.
Well,
it's news in that way.
Even if they did do that.
You're talking about individual sexual
acts between people who are male or
female,
right?
You're still talking about a man,
so talking about a man that's having sex
with other men.
You're defining it such in that way.
You're literally saying,
know a guy you are know you are saying.
You know guys who sucked other guys'
dicks.
A guy.
He's done it to a guy.
You're saying a man do it to a man.
Gotcha.
I gotcha.
No,
I'm saying that people who are
identified as men,
he did.
That's what I meant.
People who were identified as men by
society have done these things,
that society has to be unnatural for
men,
but when they were doing that,
weren't they a man doing it to a man?
Look what happened to those guys?
Historically,
not so much recently,
but certainly still today,
but certainly historically we can't keep
going back to 100 plus years.
When I was talking about like right now
I am still talking about a man who's
having a sexual exchange with another
man.
Like you can be sexually attracted to
another man.
It doesn't mean that you're both not
met.
So do you think homosexual men or men?
Sure.
Why?
Because they're male.
They have a penis,
they have x,
y chromosomes.
They can get a woman pregnant if they
wanted to,
could donate their sperm to their
lesbian pals and they just eliminated.
One of the characteristics that you
previously previously said was male.
No,
no,
no.
Most men,
most are attracted to women,
but a good percentage of them are gay
and this is not like complicated stuff.
There's still men.
Yeah.
I,
I mean,
I don't know where to go from here.
I think I've,
I think I've made the argument I,
it's,
it's funny because I thought you were
totally with me for like an hour and a
half and now it's like,
I feel like you're not there.
I didn't know what to do.
I think there's a giant spectrum of
people,
but to say that a guy is in born to a
man or a woman isn't born a woman I
think is disingenuous.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's where the.
So.
Okay.
Thailand,
Thailand.
I think in India and I think
there's several Polynesian countries.
There's several countries where there is
a legal and cultural and social category
that is neither man nor woman,
nor male or female.
Like in Thailand,
the lady boys.
Right.
And there's other countries to have
this.
You can look it up.
It's either.
Sure.
Right.
Okay.
You know about this mission.
Um,
what about that?
What about those people too?
What do you.
Oh,
well,
I think there's that too,
so.
Oh,
okay.
I'm saying people can be born a man,
but if people can be born a woman or you
can get these andy,
Dick Yoel Romero.
Weird variation.
But
Joe,
take the lady boys from Thailand and
move them here to this country.
Now,
how will they be considered?
What do you mean?
How will they be?
Americans don't have those categories.
Okay.
We have only two.
A lot of variables in Thailand.
Also,
you're dealing with like really young
sex workers.
There's a lot of weird shit that goes on
in Thailand.
A lot of abuse.
So as the ladyboy category,
real or not,
it certainly realizes the Trans category
there.
They consider that real and here we do
not,
but if it is real,
and I think you agree it's Rio and I
agree it's real,
right?
Trans people,
that means there's absolutely people
that feel like they're born in the wrong
gender,
so why isn't a man real?
Why is it a woman?
If you want to say they're all equally
real.
I'm down there.
We're good.
That's what I'm saying,
right?
It's just that those,
that,
those categories have no absolute,
you know,
biological meaning there's not a meeting
that they're fluid,
they're,
you know,
basically arbitrary.
Sorry,
I mean there that we invent them.
I'm not saying it's useless,
I'm not saying we should never have any
categories.
I'm just saying that those categories
have changed and they changed,
but you kind of,
depending on where you are in the wild
disagreeing with you,
you kind of did say that a man is born a
man and a woman isn't born and,
and for sure a lot of them are for sure.
A lot of people that have your
stereotypical classic female
characteristics were born female and for
sure there's a lot of men who have
classic,
stereotypical male behavior and patterns
and desires.
They're born men and then there's trans
people and then there's also,
there's asexual people to Charleston
needs to be considered.
Here's people that just don't have any
desire to fuck anybody.
They don't want to.
They don't want to be a man or a woman.
They can call themselves queer.
They can call themselves whatever they
want.
They don't want to be a female.
They don't want to be a male,
they just want to be human.
Here's the deal.
How about let's make a deal if you,
if that's what you have to say about it
and you want to not get in the way of
people doing those things and making
those decisions for themselves and let
them do what they want to do.
I am totally with you.
Okay.
It's true for sure.
I don't want to get in the way of
anybody making it.
furries.
That's awesome.
If you really identify with being a
giant squirrel,
that's awesome.
That's great.
And that's really what matters.
Um,
I'm just saying that claims and I want
to end it here,
claims about these essential
characteristics that it's biologically
determined,
right?
You know,
are the things that reinforce getting in
the way.
Laws,
policies,
cultures,
ideas,
norms that get in the way of people
doing what they want to do with their
own lives.
MM,
right.
Because yeah,
for sure with some people will be.
Variables are so extreme and the
spectrum is so broad.
So after I was on your show the first
time,
a got a whole bunch of comments from
people calling me a fag and a pussy and
a sissy and a this and that.
Read those feminizing me.
And it's not your fault for calling me a
girl.
You can't read those.
I know,
I know.
It's whatever.
I don't know.
I mean people like came to twitter and
whatever.
Yeah.
You don't read those?
No,
I stopped.
I learned.
Oh yeah.
Stopped.
I don't do anymore.
I didn't matter.
I didn't care.
This didn't bother me at all.
I just thought it was interesting.
I actually agreed so in other words,
and a lot of them they were really
saying and some of them elaborated on
this was that I was not really man
enough.
Right.
I was less of a man for whatever reason.
I don't know.
I don't care.
It's fine.
I liked it.
It was funny,
but it really proves my point is that
these things are very fluid.
So they kind of were kicking me out of
the category of Man and I was like,
cool,
please.
I think they were trying to get a ride,
so I now I don't think you could make a
rational argument dealing with Internet.
No,
of course not.
I'm saying it's just one example of what
goes on generally,
which is that we do this all the time,
right?
Yeah,
but they're not even human.
Like when someone's interacting with you
like that,
it's lacking all of the characteristics
of human interaction.
You're not there with a person.
You're not looking at them.
If someone was in front of you like
that,
oh,
you're a fag.
You,
you'd be like,
Oh my God,
I'm in danger.
There's a crazy person might have to
defend myself against this person
because if someone is treating me that
way,
insulting me,
looking me in the eye.
We're so close to violence like anything
can happen here.
I guess as a person.
That's not rational.
It is amazing,
isn't it?
Talking to my son as we were driving
over here,
because you know he,
he reads,
he,
he read all the comments when I was on
your shows and he was like,
it was so fun.
Is like,
toby,
don't read that shit man.
It's just,
it's funny.
Uh,
but uh,
it is remarkable how many people do
that.
Right?
And it's not just that they have these
thoughts about you,
it's that they go out of their way to
write it in public to do something that
they'll actually sit down.
That's what boggles my mind is that
someone will actually take the time and
energy to like sit there and write this
thing on youtube or whatever you know
about,
you know,
this or that about me.
It's phenomenal.
Sometimes people have good points.
No.
Sometimes they're not.
Even when they're insulting you,
sometimes they're making points while
they're insulting you.
It's just hard to separate the wheat
from the chaff.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a weird way of interacting with
people that didn't exist.
I mean,
there was never a time in our past where
you could with real time during real
instantaneously send something to
someone and then they read it right away
and they could be rude and all they are
is a twitter egg with a bunch of numbers
and letters and they call you a homo and
it's the real downside of the Internet,
which otherwise is a miraculous boon to
humanity.
I feel like it's an adolescent stage.
I feel like we are finding our way
through this inescapable new technology,
this,
this connection that we're sharing,
which is just.
Well,
it's one of the reasons why I think it's
to have
one on one conversations with people and
one of the things that I've noticed from
doing this podcast is how how many
interesting people there are there out
there in the world like yourself that I
could talk to,
but also how bad most people are in the
world.
We're just talking to each other.
We don't ever have long conversations.
Everybody's checking their fucking
phone.
Everybody's watching a television.
It's worry about that because I'm very
pro technology and all this stuff,
but that does worry me.
I want to go into a restaurant and I see
people sitting at the same table all
looking at their phones.
Oh yeah.
Like 70 precedent.
It's still like a group of seven that's
pressing and I and I have wondered about
the quality of conversation generally
because just what you're saying.
Yeah.
I've been wondering and thinking it
might actually be declining.
The quality of our conversations.
Personally.
I definitely think it is.
I find myself continually disappointed
with very smart people that I meet that
don't have real conversation.
They talk over people.
They don't.
They're not listening.
They're not responding to what you're
saying.
They're waiting for you to stop talking
so they can talk and it's like,
it's like this self centered sort of way
of interacting with each other.
That seems more prevalent than not.
I'm used to that because I'm around
academics a lot because they're used to
lecturing and that they're the smartest
person in the room and so all their job
is to do is to tell us what's true.
Right?
So they're,
they're very comfortable with that.
I was always amazed when I'd watch these
are really important famous professors
at Columbia,
you know,
give these lectures to the hall of 500
people in.
It seemed to me they didn't even know
that there are other people in the room
the way they were talking.
Like it didn't matter what the reactions
were,
whether people were asleep,
whether they're reading the newspaper,
they just didn't care.
They just kept going.
He kept talking to talk and talk for two
hours straight ahead.
You know,
I just,
I can't do that.
I'm the exact opposite.
I panic if I feel like the person I'm
talking to isn't listening to me.
That's good.
I panic.
Yeah.
And so when I see if I'm lecturing to
200 students,
I see one kid kind of just get a little
distracted.
I freak and I feel like I have to up my
game right then and I have to go
directly address them.
That means you care.
Yeah.
I mean,
whatever it is,
I care in a particular way.
I mean,
it's some,
it's another form of narcissism I
suppose,
but I really,
I do think that's what makes me a good
teacher because I,
I have to have interaction will you want
to connect,
they need to know what you're hearing,
right?
I need to know what you're hearing from
me.
That's the thing,
and then we can really talk and then I
also am really curious.
I'm just a curious person and I want to
know what you're thinking and let's do
this,
you know,
let's.
And then let's have that chemistry that
happened just now,
which got hot,
you know,
but like that's,
that's where life is.
That's where real personal relationships
are.
Yeah.
Comics kind of do the same thing too
because they're used to being the one
who's talking on stage or if they do a
podcast,
they're used to being the one who's
talking all the time.
The ones who do crowd work.
Right.
Amazing.
If you think about it,
if they're the ones who interact,
have a whole part of their act where
it's crowd work.
Most comics,
I mean don't they have some indirect?
Yeah,
definitely the interaction with the
crowd and happens a lot.
I mean you're dealing with people
drinking alcohol
in a social environment and it's dark
out and it's nighttime and they're
having fun and they're laughing and and
especially when you're talking about
controversial opinions in subjects,
people always,
all the comics talk about,
you know,
you feel the room,
you feel that interaction.
I'm saying I'm talking about these
professors and they're tweed jackets at
Columbia.
I swear to God it didn't matter what
happened,
what was happening and the lecturer is a
certain amount of arrogance and I'm sure
you must get after being a professor,
it's a particular narcissism.
They live entirely in their heads,
right?
They just sit in their study and read
books and then they go out and then give
a lecture and then they come back and
read this,
read the book and you know,
it's a weird narcissism.
I can't really get to interact with
other professors and go over there,
work together.
You know,
I am stereotyping and generalizing.
This is not everybody,
but I did see this a lot and I still do.
Yeah,
there's some interactions,
but again,
it's mostly through,
you know,
you write a paper and then you send it
out to the journal and then some other
professor reviews it write anonymously
often and sends it back.
It's all very weird passive aggressive
shit too.
Like that's the other thing about
academia I can't stand is that they are
allergic to direct conflict.
Like the argument you and I just had,
that's pretty much not allowed except
through writing.
They'll do it through writing,
but they won't do it head to head.
That's a real problem because it takes
too long to work out an idea that way.
Yeah.
Like real debate.
When I went to college I had this idea
that it would be really smart people,
like professors,
like more than one would be in a room
and they would have,
you know,
one major issue and they would debate it
that there would be argument,
right.
There'll be conflict of ideas about an
idea.
No,
it's not that.
It's never that I have been in and
around college campuses for 32 years.
I have never really seen a head to head
debate.
Like even I just had,
that's insane.
Person to person,
I mean here and there a little bit,
but not like that.
Not what we're really,
really going at it.
I don't think I've ever seen that.
I mean the enemy among faculty.
Some students do,
but faculty don't.
They're scared of it.
I'm telling you,
there's a problem with cowardice and one
of the real tragedies with that is that
as I said,
there's no real conflict of ideas which
is reinforced by the tenure system,
the accreditation system.
It's a,
it's this monolith where there's one,
and this is why you get this uniformity,
the uniformity of the ideas on campuses.
It's all this monolith that actually has
its head at the federal government.
Do you know about the accreditation
system?
Would it be?
If it's the mafia,
people don't even know this.
To get accredited as a college or
university in this country,
you have to be accredited by an agency
that is,
that is authorized by the Department of
Education in Washington DC.
The secretary of Education has to
authorize your existence as a legitimate
legal college or university.
That's it.
So renegade university people were
asking me,
they wanted me,
they want some people want to call it
credit and I was like,
Oh,
let me look into this.
And so I did and I quickly found out
that it's the fucking mafia that I
couldn't get accredited because they
have all these,
they have all these standards.
You have to have a particular number of
buildings,
a particular number of professors.
You have to have a library with a
particular number of books in it.
You have to have a gym,
you have to drop all these things and if
you don't have those things you're not
in,
you don't get that.
You don't get college credit,
no other.
So what if you did like I gave you five
credits for taking one of my courses?
No other college and university would
recognize it if you want it to transfer,
like you wanted to go to graduate school
or go somewhere else,
do something.
No,
employers would look at it and see that
it's not an accredited university where
you've got those credits from.
So how do those degree mills,
how do they do it?
Right.
So there's two different systems at the
Department of Education controls.
One is for the so called elite
prestigious schools.
Those are regional accreditation
agencies.
Again,
all authorized by the Department of
Education and the for profit colleges.
There's a separate accreditation system
called the national accreditation system
and that's also controlled by the
department of education,
but everybody knows within it that if
you get,
if you get accredited by one of the
national accreditation system,
zero bullshit for profit the Greenville.
So those credits,
you can't transfer them to Harvard or
occidental or any of the of the elite so
called elite schools.
So they're completely kept separate.
But you can't even if you get a degree
from like Phoenix University,
you know that you can't.
You can get 5,000 degrees from Phoenix
University.
My degree is,
I can't take anywhere and I'm talking
about even even community colleges won't
accept those credits.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
It's the mafia.
So think about that,
right?
The Department of Education,
one person,
federal government decides who's in,
who's out,
and then inside that system there's
tenure,
lifetime appointment.
Those people control the curriculum,
what is taught.
They also control who's hired and fired
faculty control all the hiring and
firing of faculty and tenure.
They ultimately control that basically.
Right.
And they're there forever like dawns in
the Mafia.
Seriously.
So you wonder why when you walk into any
college classroom in this country,
you hear basically the same shit being
said and sociology classes and history
classes.
That's why it's astonishing.
And I didn't even know the full extent
of it until I started renegade
university and people started asking me
about this.
What if you were,
if someone allowed you to come along,
if Donald Trump said that,
he says,
I love your work.
Uh,
what,
what could you do to fix that?
What would you offer as an alternative?
We have to change it.
No,
there's nothing I do.
I mean meaning,
if he wanted credit,
like college credit,
right now there's really nothing I can
do.
I can certainly give them a certificate
and maybe an employer will think it's
meaningful because my name's on it.
Is it less and less valuable to have a
degree today?
I'm saying I'm just completely outside
the system.
Right,
I understand.
Yeah.
But like,
if you,
if you admired me and my work right,
and you saw and I had and he had a
certificate saying this guy's great and
he took my course,
you as an employer,
it would actually help.
Sure.
And then in that case it would be
meaningful.
My credits,
I'm just saying that's completely
outside.
It means nothing inside the system of
the thousands and thousands of colleges
and universities.
And for most employers,
right?
Most employers abide by this.
They think that if you're not
accredited,
your bullshit.
So we have to change it.
And Betsy devoss for whatever her
problems are,
seems to be the first secretary of
education maybe we've ever had who could
be willing to challenge this.
Really?
Yeah.
Because she's about deregulation and
privatization and all this stuff and
choice school choice.
Um,
and we need a movement right now before
she's gone to get her to abolish the
national accreditation system all with a
stroke of a pen,
I think.
And maybe a congressional act probably
takes a congressional act to.
But she herself I think could discredit.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure she could discredit all
those agencies right now.
So you think there's just this inherent
bottleneck that it's existed for so long
and that these people have been in
charge of saying what is true and what's
not true?
What should it be taught in monopoly,
a monopoly ultimately controlled by the
federal government that it's also not
universally agreed that they're correct.
Correct.
In what they're teaching and it's not
like there's a,
an absolute standard for what needs to
be taught if someone wants to get into.
No,
no,
there are up.
I mean there are absolute standards.
This is what I'm saying,
like you have to have this,
that,
and the other thing on your college
campus to be accredited.
No,
that's what I mean.
I mean,
in terms of like what is,
uh,
what,
what constitutes a master's degree in
literature,
right.
Like,
is there an absolute standard?
Yeah,
for the.
Yes.
The,
well,
they're pretty absolute.
I mean,
accreditation agencies mostly agree on
those things.
So why couldn't you just reproduce that
in an environment where you're being
taught by someone who obviously has a
mastery of that particular subject?
That's what Joe.
That's what I'm doing.
Yeah,
that's what we're doing.
Well,
that's what's happened.
It's not just me,
right?
I'm,
you know,
one of the pioneers.
But it's happening.
How many other people are doing what?
You're doing a handful.
I mean,
but it's becoming a new Jordan Peterson
is actually looking at.
When I heard him talking about that on
your show,
I said,
go for it,
man.
Yeah.
Well he didn't grant.
We know what he said.
He was no criticism at all.
I didn't know this either until
recently.
He,
he had this idea.
What was it about accreditation?
He thought it was possible somehow to
get accredited,
but it's not.
You can't.
We have to start an entirely separate
parallel,
different system Canada.
Uh,
possibly it could be.
That could be credited and possible.
But anyway,
regardless,
I am all for him doing that.
I hope he does.
I will tell you,
it was recently denied.
A grant for the first time is Debit
Korea.
I'm sure they're not playing around.
They're not playing around on this is
their castle.
They're not going to let us.
The Naves in.
Well,
what's interesting is because of social
media,
because of coming on podcasts like mine
and his youtube presence,
he's actually got a large movement of
people that are interested in his ideas.
He had a disastrous fucking conversation
with Sam Harris.
I don't know if I heard it.
I did.
What in the fuck was that all about?
Well,
he's holding onto God.
the first one wasn't even that.
It was about truth.
That was God though.
It was.
Yeah,
because Jordan had religious and he
believes he's religious,
so he wants to hold onto this idea about
what is truth being valuable for
humankind versus what is truth.
Like one plus one equals two.
Right.
Moral moral truth versus I was kind of
on either side and that one was so
verbose but was too many words.
It was like,
you guys gotTa fucking edit this down.
It was tough with Jordan had to boil it
down and they did a way better podcast
the second time.
Did you hear the second one?
Much,
much better.
Much more concise.
Much clear,
but that again,
this,
I think there was this certain amount of
healed digging on both sides.
They dug their heels in,
they stood their ground.
This one really preposterous issue,
which just like,
you know,
you're listening to this like Jesus
fucking Christ.
Guys,
you just talking about truth for an hour
and a half.
Like,
what is truth?
Here's what's true.
Fire Burns paper.
That's fucking true.
Okay.
Like take a piece of paper.
Write it on fire.
So stop.
Goddammit.
You're going to make me go again.
I don't want to have this conversation
now.
It's really important,
but let's leave it there as well.
So I did agree with them,
Sam and Jordan.
That is really important.
I just disagree with them about what,
what's going on.
But anyway,
um,
the definition of the word true,
but you know what should be,
they should have had more leeway on both
sides with that.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so either way,
here's the thing,
he said,
fascinating guy.
Totally.
I have major disagreements with Sam
Jordan,
but there's still heroic and I'm totally
with them because they are doing this.
I mean Sam's not doing it formally,
but he's essentially part of this
movement.
You're a part of this movement.
You know what the Donald,
you know what the election was about.
It was about a civil war in this country
that's been going on for a long time.
That finally came to a head in November,
which is a war between the people who
went to college and the elite colleges
in particular and who are of that
culture that's created in those colleges
and those who are not of that culture.
That's what that.
That's what that election was about.
I think there is this schism between
those two groups in this country and
that finally the people who are not of
the elite college culture one something
and it caused the elites to freak
completely out.
So if you look at,
like I was looking at the top podcast
because I just started a podcast and it
did get ranked and so I'm excited but
I'm looking at it a lot and like you can
really see it clearly to look at the top
podcasts right now.
It's like 60 to 70 percent are like NPR,
cookie cutter,
same shit.
Coastal elite,
liberal bland,
you know,
you know what it is,
tone of voice,
what they say,
who their guests are.
All the same.
You know exactly what it is,
right?
Is dominated by that.
But then there's you in there.
You're not that.
There's Sam Harris who sort of that,
but not really.
You know,
there's Dan Carlin here,
there's another one,
right?
He's part of this movement.
He doesn't have a school,
but he's teaching people history.
Oh fuck.
Teaching people history.
A lot of people history,
more people than any historic.
A Harvard professor will ever teach you
more than any historian,
more way more.
He gets millions of downloads.
Way History lecture.
Is anybody in the numbers like millions
producing?
Does he?
Is he a serious historian?
I've listened to him.
I'm a professionally trained historian,
Ivy League Phd.
Hell yeah.
He is.
You know,
I don't agree with everything,
but it doesn't matter.
He's doing serious academic,
professional,
important history and he is changing the
landscape.
I agree.
Okay.
He's on there,
so there's.
Some of us were there,
some of us we're making,
we're making it happen,
but you can just see as such a divide,
like there's just such a divide between
like who,
who's on your podcast and who's on the
NPR podcasts is hardly any crossover.
Yeah,
but that's just my choice.
Interesting.
That could know those people.
There's a lot of people that I get that
are on NPR podcasts.
My point is that there's sort of two
different cultures that's happening
right now.
There's just that culture like,
and this is kind of a problem with my
girlfriend and I have because she's of
that culture.
Most of the people I know are npr types,
you know,
that's what they want to hear.
It's comforting and soothing,
whatever.
It makes them feel good.
I don't know,
but they're really.
That's who they are.
Fundamentally.
It's like their identity and then,
you know,
when they hear your podcast or my
podcast or anyone's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like a punk rock to a 80 year old.
It's just hard.
It's just different culture,
different language,
different way of behaving,
different ideas or questions,
different questions are asked.
Um,
and there's,
there's this resentment to,
because the elites,
the MPR types I believe have basically
looked,
not basically they have looked down
their noses at those who didn't go to
college who don't speak the way we
speak,
who don't talk about these ideas,
who aren't aware of these ideas.
Right?
Working class people like people in
Salem.
I know people who,
Oh,
you know,
Meryl Streep said at best,
right about mma,
right St.
that's,
that was it right there.
They clearly see all those people
outside this elite by coastal culture as
doing bad stuff,
inferior stuff,
and they shouldn't be allowed to run
things.
She said was so inherently ridiculous
and also ignorant because she was also
claiming that if you take out the
immigrants,
you're left with mma.
MMA is 80 percent immigrants.
Sure.
Literally.
Well,
what she said was,
was stupid,
ignorant,
and more importantly,
I think classist in that way.
Right?
It's like,
you're not smart enough.
You're not good enough.
She's so wrong.
Like there's a lot of Americans that
engaged now in May for sure,
but there's so many great fighters that
are immigrants.
I mean a massive,
massive amounts.
It's not small mouth,
so she was saying,
take out all the immigrants you left
with mma.
That is so dumb,
but you know what those people do with
the.
The immigrants who do things like mma,
they ignore them.
They pretend.
They pretend they don't exist.
It doesn't fit the narrow narrative.
Yeah.
Is the immigrant who also very much
exists.
They want the undocumented mom with the
kid who got stopped at the border and
sent back.
Who breaks my heart too?
Yeah,
my two.
Absolutely,
but they want them only to be what?
Victims.
What's the solution to that?
That they can say,
what is the solution to illegal
immigration in this country?
Do you just let everybody in?
I'm an open border sky.
Yeah.
Open borders.
Just let anybody in who wants to come
meeting of inventions and social
constructs that have done great harm to
humanity.
Borders,
borders.
Yeah.
I agree that eventually that's going to
be a thing of the past.
I think there'll be a looked back when
we look back at history.
It'll be thought of as one of the most
barbaric ideas,
right?
Can you imagine?
Let's say it's barbaric and the way that
it used to be that you had a tribe,
then you invaded another tribe or they
invaded you and you had to put up a
fence and guard your border and then
these things became like larger
communities as communities became.
Cities became countries became and then
you go back a few thousand years.
You're dealing with these countries
invading other countries and so you have
these,
uh,
immigration policies,
especially now where we have border
patrols and this idea that you have to
have your paperwork and you have to have
passports and numbers and otherwise you,
you were born in the wrong patch of
dirt.
Sir.
If you were just born 30 miles north,
you could have been in Texas,
but you're in Juarez.
You fuck,
so you stay over here.
It's,
it's silly.
Speaking of social constructions and
social constructions that have changed
over time,
right?
It's damn telling a Mexican they can't
come here.
Are you crazy like this was Mexico five
minutes ago.
You assholes.
Who the fuck are you finishing the
arrogance of Americans who think that
Mexicans have no place here?
I mean,
there weren't no white people here long.
Well,
it not only that,
I mean you just got lucky you're,
you were born into this like
economically prov promising area where
you know,
you gotta better opportunities.
Sure.
And you're looking at these people that
are born in a shit spot and you're like,
well,
you're in that shit spot forever.
You can't come over here and take my
good spot.
It also works against us because then it
becomes harder for us to travel
elsewhere because then they have
borders.
They don't like Americans because of
what we do to them.
When I go to Mexico in a,
I just like,
I love it there and I keep thinking,
man,
it's amazing that you're treating me
this well because the Mexicans are so
kind.
Generally,
you know,
when you're down there and like,
God,
you should hate Americans.
Wha What we've done to them in terms of
the border integration and that drug
war.
I mean,
the deaths,
the poverty that we've inflicted on them
through these laws are shitty policy.
My God,
I mean they have every reason to hate
our guts and they don't.
Yeah,
well no.
Mexicans overall are very kind people.
My parents live in Mexico.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
I love Mexico.
I love it.
I going to Mexico all the time and
credible place.
I try to go out of my favorite places to
go on vacation for sure.
And I know a lot of people.
I have a lot of friends here.
They're scared.
They're scared of Mexico.
I think Mexico is all gang violence and
all that.
I'm like,
wow,
read about Chicago.
You're not scared to go to Chicago.
Chicago was fucking murders every day.
That's a good point.
I want to trump Chicago,
Mexico violence.
You know what he was saying about these
illegal immigrants being violent
criminals and stuff.
He wasn't wrong entirely.
A,
here's what.
Here's what people are ignoring that
it's true that the cartels have moved
into the Midwest.
You know about this in particular
Chicago,
that Chapo and others too.
They have moved into the Midwest there
in Kentucky.
Do a google search for like Mexican
cartel and pick like a town in Kentucky
and Ohio,
Indiana.
They're all over the midwest and they're
competing.
They're kicking out the old gangs and
that's why there's all this violence on
the streets.
A lot of those black kids in Chicago who
are shooting each other are working for
one of those cartels basically,
so trump was right about that,
but he's totally wrong about the answer
to it and what liberals do in response
to it is even worse,
which is pretend it's not happening.
Yeah,
no,
people are killing each other,
but why?
Why?
Because drugs are illegal.
Yes,
because drugs are illegal and we want
them to be illegal.
We vote for those laws.
Well,
I met a guy in Chicago who was a cop and
he explained it to me in great detail
and he said essentially what happened is
they moved in and they arrested a lot of
these drug lords,
these local people that were in charge
of whatever areas and they were running
whatever criminal organization.
They arrest them and they created a
power vacuum and the way he was saying,
he's like,
it's no different than when we remove a
dictator in some foreign country that
people move in and then it creates
violence.
You get isis.
Exactly,
exactly.
Yeah.
So,
but you don't hear people talking about
this.
Right.
It's incredible.
That's what's going on.
Yes.
The cartels are here.
Trump has drugs.
Really trump is too god damn dumb to
make the full point and he's also
beholden to these asshole republicans
like jeff sessions who thinks that I
think that marijuana is dangerous.
He wants to bring back.
So he's not saying he's not.
He has no idea,
or at least he's not saying what the
actual causes.
Right.
And Liberals are sort of a betting him
by ignoring it,
but saying,
well no,
there is no violence.
It's like no fuckers.
There is tremendous violence and that
cause is your laws against drugs.
Right?
So the answer is really simple.
It's in glass trucks.
Yeah.
So,
but because,
because our government is just a fight
between this moron trump and these
morons,
the Democrats who refused to address
this stuff,
there's no discussion about it.
But if you do legalized drugs,
like how do you do that?
Like say if the United States just
decided we're going to decriminalize all
drugs and now that's not good enough
because someone's going to sell them.
Right?
You can't just decriminalize them,
but that just keeps people from getting
arrested,
which is a great step.
A good,
a good move in the right direction.
There's some insane number of people in
America that are in prison right now for
nonviolent drug offenses.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a nutty number.
That's a side note,
but a really important one.
There is now a debate among academics
who study this stuff,
uh,
and a lot of academics who are actually
more or less on the right side of this
are arguing that the drug war and,
and making drugs illegal is not the
major cause of mass incarceration
because the number,
the percentage of people it is big,
but it's something like 10 percent who
are nonviolent drug offenders who were,
who were prosecuted and convicted of
just drug offenses.
That is a relatively small number,
but what they're not taking into account
is all of the other crimes that stem
from drugs being illegal.
Right?
So all the murders,
all the assault,
the violent take,
all the homicides in this country.
Right.
I want to see a number,
but I'm sure it's really high of how
many were committed by a gang member.
Okay.
And how many of the gangs in the United
States basically started by selling
drugs?
Right,
right.
Okay.
There's that homicides,
assault gangs,
drugs,
there is larceny theft.
People who are hooked on drugs who are
broke in large part because drug prices
are so high.
Why are they so high?
Because they're illegal.
Right,
right.
They have to get them on.
The black market always raises prices,
so they're forced to steal because
they're poor people.
Right.
So a huge percentage and they don't
track this because the convictions are,
you know,
if it's,
if it's a junkie who steals from
somebody to score,
they don't count that as a drug crime.
They counted as just Larson a.
So we don't know,
but I am sure,
and this is what social scientists need
to do right now is start to make that,
do that work and find out exactly how
many people are in prison for some
reason related to the fact that drugs
are illegal and a Betcha it's a huge
number.
Yeah,
I bet you're right.
It's also like these gangs,
if they don't sell drugs,
they have no other method of income
because they're just knocking over
trucks filled with equipment and then
reselling it.
Like where,
what are they doing?
They have no income.
They have no power.
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
So I mean the mafia in the 19 twenties
was enormously powerful.
Hugely powerful.
Why?
Because the prohibition.
Exactly.
So that's you take away.
I said,
I've said this to people like,
um,
what was,
the great netflix series was about him,
the huge drug.
No champion.
Narcos.
Yup.
It goes,
was named Paul Escobar Escobar Escobar.
So take make drugs you make.
If drugs were legal,
how many people did Escobar kill?
None or two or one or something,
right?
I mean he killed thousands of people.
Right?
But if they're legal,
here's the
deal,
like who's profiting off of those?
Right.
That's where it gets really slippery.
If you make drugs legal and then there's
got to be,
like right now,
the people that are selling them are
criminals,
right?
If they're not,
if you make it illegal,
they're going to still sell them.
Like they're just going to sell them
legally.
Like,
like how do you make this transition
between drugs being legal and then
people being able to sell them.
Like how does that work?
How do you do that in an orderly way?
How do you preserve sanity and humanity
and civilization?
What do you mean?
Nineteen,
33.
They ended prohibition.
Yeah.
But alcohol was something that did
though.
What's that?
They regulated it heavily.
[inaudible],
which made which created new problems,
it caused the state to be all up in our
business and all sorts of ways,
so like you had to get licensed to sell
alcohol,
right?
Which is what that meant was an
inspector from the state came to your
bar or restaurant or whatever and looked
around and asked you questions and
checked on who we're hiring,
who worked there,
who your customers were,
what kinds of customers,
and if you didn't fit all the rules of
polite society or in.
This was true.
Great histories have been done about
this.
If you had the homosexuals coming into
your bar,
Oh,
drunk,
homos.
You don't want that for the prostitutes
or the prostitutes coming into your bar,
or even women who were a little bit
loose with their morality.
You didn't get a license.
Really?
Yes.
Women could stop you from getting a bar
license.
Absolutely.
Boy,
I don't know what kind of world we live
in telling you,
so just decriminalize.
We will be fine,
but if you just decriminalized who's
selling it,
right,
it's still going to be illegal to sell.
No.
Right.
Decriminalization doesn't mean
legalization in terms of profitability,
right?
Mexico.
Do you know that all drugs essentially
or decriminalized in Mexico,
including mushrooms,
acid.
These are those definitions changed
according to the industry,
which is a pain in the ass.
But so sometimes decrim means just no
laws at all.
No,
none.
Legalization usually means not always,
but usually means regulations.
Like what happened with.
Yeah.
So like with weed,
we've got legal,
we've got legalized and it's heavily
regulated and Cetera,
but it also was not that heavily were
regulated in Colorado it's pretty easy
to get.
I thought it was while the regulation
comes in the banking,
the banking is weird because the federal
government still has it classified as a
schedule one substance and it's illegal.
So there's a huge issue isn't it?
For people having an accept cash only.
So they hired a bunch of seals and
burkes and all these fucking guys from
like,
you know,
that would have probably worked for like
a mercenary organizations.
Now they're fucking Karen round drug
money from people selling pot and then
they have to take it to the bank and put
it in safe deposit boxes.
And deposited into these accounts in
weird ways.
It's very fucking.
It's really problematic.
And that keeps a lot of people out of
the market,
out of participating in this.
It hire soldiers,
you know,
stuff that peaceful unemployment
program.
That's great.
That's what we need more,
more hired.
Uh,
isn't it true that they give them jobs?
You don't want them not having jobs.
And that's true.
Once you teach people how to kill
people,
we'll be nice to them.
I certainly would rather them do that.
Then killing Iraqis,
they also disallowed people with prior
felonies from participating in the
industry.
Is that true?
In Colorado,
which I've seen this and that meant it's
all white.
I do not know that.
All the,
all the.
Well there's a lot of black producers.
Celanese racist bastard.
How dare you got assigned to you?
That was a,
that was a complete,
like Huffington post item,
I just know.
Right.
And you call it racist.
Wow.
I don't know what to do now.
Have a system or a salon.
It's kind of a salon.com.
Not Man.
I'm all right,
man.
We did just did three hours am.
No Way.
Flew by letting before 30.
Global.
Yeah.
Time flies when you're having fun.
Tell everybody what your podcast is.
Tell everybody where they can get it.
Cool.
Yeah.
I've got a few things going on,
but yeah,
the unregistered with that.
Yes.
Russell,
the podcast and Thaddeus Russell Dot
com.
There's a page for the cartoons tonight,
everywhere.
Top 50 and news and politics right now,
and then I got renegade university.
I got an event coming up in
Massachusetts in August.
Joe's old stomping grounds.
Salem,
Massachusetts.
August fourth through sixth.
What are you doing out there?
It's a weekend and burning witches.
Whole weekend.
The whole weekend seminar.
I'm talking about history and theory and
politics and all weekend and I've
already sold out the VIP,
but there's more.
The general admission is still on sale
and then I'm doing that with a great
group,
which I meant to mention.
School sucks.
Project who was actually one of the very
first pioneers of this whole movement I
was talking about to just overthrow the
whole educational system and replace it
with actual thought and ideas and
debate.
Who is running this?
His name is Brett [inaudible],
not great guy.
He's been doing is just running a
podcast.
He was just,
he was a teacher in New Hampshire and he
just,
he was too smart for that system and got
sick of it and he left and said,
I'm just going to do a podcast.
You had no platform,
you know,
not a celebrity at all.
And it grew and grew and grew and he's
got this huge following and you talk to
him.
I'll have him on.
Awesome.
I'd love to have bread is amazing and
he's got this big following and he's had
me on the show a lot so he and I are co
producing renegade university in school.
Sucks project or co producing,
presenting this weekend in Salem and
August fourth through the sixth,
so you can go to school sucks.
Project website or Thaddeus Russell Dot
com website to get all the details and
buy the tickets there.
And then I have a seminar actually in La
just with me.
Just 20 people for four weeks talking
about renegade history.
The United States,
four weeks,
four nights.
Oh,
over over four weeks.
So it's for Thursday night,
Thursday night for four weeks.
That's it.
I'm right here in la,
west side renegade history.
The United States have just with me in
20 people and that's how my whip and it
starts next Thursday.
Excellent.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
yeah,
my website's got a bunch of stuff,
but that's,
that's it.
I'm busy,
man.
I'm really busy but it sounds awesome.
Thank you so much.
Stop getting hit in the head.
Okay.
I'll try.
Don't do it.
Be Sparring with people smarter next.
All right,
beautiful.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it man.
Daddy's for bar with everlast from the
house of pain.